there was blood in the water but at
least the screaming had stopped it had
been an ill-advised party boat floating
out in Dangerous Waters where a bachelor
party full of rich and naive men had
ignored every warning some had told them
don't you know that pirates operate in
these Waters others had cautioned you
might get confused for pirates and shot
down by military boats nobody had
expected The Impossible monster that had
actually killed all 10 people who' gone
out there on that warm ocean night but
in the chaos that unfolded the day after
they would find out a cargo ship
carrying hundreds of millions of dollars
with the products invaluable raw
materials was scheduled to cross those
same Waters if they could have gone any
other way they would have but with
corporate shipping deadlines to reach
they couldn't afford to take the scenic
route and potentially add over an entire
week to an already long trip the cargo
ship would need to take the risk they
would need to face the pirates on their
own turf if it came to that meanwhile on
a number of secret compounds on land the
Pirates were preparing their corrupt
government shipping sources had given
them a valuable tip about the coming
ship and they were doing everything they
could in order to ensure this flagrant
Act of piracy would be successful they
loaded fuel into the tanks of their
speedboats they clicked magazines full
of armor-piercing bullets into their
AK-47s they slipped on bulletproof body
armor and clipped grenades to their
belts they were a terrifying force to be
reckoned with but they had no idea that
within a few hours they would be
encountering something far more
dangerous you see strange things had
been happening on some of the world's
coastlines it started with Surfers fool
hearty sun-kissed Thrill Seekers with an
addiction to catching the biggest waves
possible of course there are plenty of
surfers who get claimed by the Sea every
year it is an occupational hazard
especially for fledgling Surfers but the
mysterious circumstances of all the
workers had something in common blood in
the water of course it didn't stop with
Surfers anyone who swam a few feet
further than the edge of the water
seemed to be at risk lonely Moonlight
swimmers went first but it didn't take
long for whole families to start
disappearing in the waves a few here a
few there nothing that most people even
noticed just a whole bunch of
unconnected isolated tragedies the sea
is a cruel mistress though when looking
at these cases nobody ever considered
that something else entirely could be
behind all these terrifying
disappearances but back to the cargo
ship making its way across the turbulent
Waters and those Waters were indeed
turbulent far choppier than the forecast
had predicted the waves were huge
towering even but that was no excuse to
delay their important Mission their
comms had recently received a communic
from the local government about the
missing party boat and all its occupants
assumed dead the previous night Pirates
most likely the cargo ship had come
prepared for this eventuality the
company sponsoring their efforts had
lost too much time and money to let
their ships be sitting ducks floating
goodie bags for violent criminals that's
why they'd spent a little extra money on
a precaution heavily armed mercenaries
patrolling the ship ready to kill in
order to protect their boss's products
the scene is set for a blood bath and
certain things out there in the deep
love a good blood bath the Pirates ready
to make a lot of money by any means
necessary loaded into their ships and
speedboats their assault rifles slung on
their backs they took to the waters
howling battlecries as they zeroed in on
the cargo ship across the Bucking waves
they prepared to fire but they didn't
expect their target to fire back with no
mercy The Mercenaries ran to the edge of
the boat and started f firing down on
the smaller boats surrounding them with
machine guns several Pirates went down
chalk full of bullets dead before they
could even figure out what was going on
as their bodies sank amidst the waves
their blood floated on the surface like
big red plumes while the Pirates were
shocked at the resistance they weren't
unprepared you don't get to become the
rulers of this particularly tough part
of the ocean without being ready to give
it even harder than you can take it in
accordance with this the Pirates loaded
up the handful of RPGs they brought out
with them and fired their deadly
payloads at the side of the cargo ship
boom boom boom the ship was rocked by
explosions knocking over some of the
many mercenaries standing on the hole
some fell screaming down into the water
where Pirates quickly cut them down with
bursts of Ruthless gunfire but one
mercenary who fell off the back of the
boat got lucky or unlucky depending on
your perspective no pirate spotted him
him potentially leaving him safe and
sound until he noticed a large wave
coming towards him it took more than a
little water to frighten this hardened
Soldier of Fortune until he saw
something nightmarish hiding in the dark
the flash of white fangs and an ivory
jaw it hinged open and bore down on him
as the wave prepared to crash the
mercenary screamed and after the wave
hit him he was gone meanwhile the
violent battle between the mercenaries
on the cargo ship and the Pirates trying
to claim it raged on using grappling
hooks the Pirates were climbing up onto
the hull having disabled the back Rudder
with sustained gunfire and targeted
bombing the ship was soon suffused with
Bloodshed as pirates and mercenaries
gunned each other down in bloody combat
men were falling left and right but
there always seemed to be more little by
little as each man fell there was more
and more blood in the water out in the
depths as a storm began to rage and the
waves whipped and roared something
hungry could smell and taste the blood
one boat full of pirates kept circling
the cargo ship like a Hungry Shark one
worked the engine with practiced
efficiency while another three aimed
AK-47s up at the ship waiting for the
moment when another unfortunate
mercenary stuck up his head ready to
receive a bullet but their true enemy
wasn't even on the ship it was sneaking
up behind them only the man working the
speedboats engine spotted it before it
was too late a wave rose out of the sea
moving with a speed that shocked even
this veteran seaf farer at first he
thought nothing of it too busy to keep
out of the range of mercenary bullets he
was hardly the type to worry about
getting wet and then he saw the teeth as
the wave Rose well above his height and
only a few feet away he saw something
impossible floating in the water a shape
he'd been seeing hanging above the
fireplace and a bar he'd been
frequenting for years the jaws and teeth
of a great white shark perhaps it was
just refu from a dead shark floating in
the water that was the most reasonable
explanation right but if that was the
case why would the Jaws be spreading
further apart as though ready to receive
him he screamed so loud that his crew
mates first assumed he'd taken a bullet
but when they turned around they saw the
truth a huge wave was crashing down on
them and they saw the teeth not just one
set the one that the engine man had seen
but a different set of teeth for each of
them
Hungry Shark mouths without sharks
bearing down they all screamed their
desperate sounds of Terror blending into
an incoherent chorus before being cut
off by the crash of the Waves the boat
was wrecked empty and Blood Stained when
the water dissipated sinking lifelessly
to the bottom of the ocean but of course
the worst was yet to come the anomally
in the waves was ins satiated all the
mercenaries and Pirates it had taken so
far were just the appetite ier and now
it was ready for the main course
everyone now on the cargo ship pirate
mercenary and sailor caught in between
who was fighting and even dying for
money had no idea what was coming the
wave rumbled and Rose behind the ship
getting taller and taller and taller
until even the giant vessel looked like
a toy boat in its wake in the darkness
of the wave hundreds of pairs of nashing
shark jaws the sharp edges of their
teeth glisten
the wave fell upon the ship sending
flesh eating water coursing through
every nook and cranny when the water
cleared there wasn't a single Survivor
the ship irreparably broken sank to a
metal graveyard down below nobody in the
normal world would even know what
happened for those with a fear of sharks
and deep water this particular anomaly
is a living Nightmare and one that the
French division of the SCP Foundation
has encountered with unsettled Ling
frequency it's been recorded manifesting
off a number of different coastlines and
who even knows how often it's manifested
out in deeper waters despite its uclid
classification containing this anomaly
has been no mean feat it's involved
shutting down a number of coastlines
completely on the pretense of animal
research the administration of Class A
amnestics to Witnesses and class b
amnestics to victims as well as a
complicated disinformation campaign to
suppress photos and reports of the
phenomenon on online but even with all
of these containment procedures in place
many have still lost their lives to the
jaws of SCP 054 dfr or the Great White
Wave by the foundation's current
estimations recorded attacks by the
Great White Wave have been fatal 68% of
the time with survivors often
experiencing wounds consistent with
those of an abnormally bad shark attack
in case our opening case study didn't
clue you in the Great White Wave is a
set of ravenous shark jaws most closely
resembling the karadon karius or great
white shark manifesting inside ocean
waves any waves over 4 M tall can become
a host to a Great White Wave event with
there theoretically being no upper limit
to the size of a wave capable of causing
this kind of anomalous catastrophe the
power of the great white waves bite is
also directly proportional to the size
of the wave it manifests on two meaning
that in theory a tsunami playing host to
the Great wide wave could devour an
entire town while every attack that the
foundation has failed to prevent is of
course a tragedy the number of attacks
has allowed the foundation to uncover
some extremely interesting data for
example while attacks Could Happen
anywhere at Sea they most common in the
250 M ocean radius around a coastline
when a human or non- aquatic animal is
present in the attack zone Great White
waves move at three times the speed of a
normal wave in pursuit of its
unfortunate press prey the Great White
Wave isn't picky about its prey either
divers swimmers and even aquatic
Vehicles like boats or jet skis have
been devoured though the waves seem to
show a particular preference for Surfers
which is gnarly in the typical sense but
not in the sense that Surfers say it the
ghostly shark jaws will only become
visible next to the part of the wave
closest to the victim meaning that they
often aren't spotted until it's too late
but that doesn't mean it can't consume
mult multiple victims at once as you saw
with the unfortunate Sailors and pirates
in our opening story many sets of Jaws
can manifest in the case of having
multiple victims to Devour the actual
consumption occurs as the wave crashes
down upon the victim so the only
recorded way to survive being on the
wrong side of the Great White Wave is to
dive into the water before the wave
crashes the French division of the
foundation conducted a series of
experiments in hopes of understanding
the Dynamics of the Great White Wave
which had results both encouraging and
disturbing based on non-anomalous
shark's ability to electromagnetically
sense blood from extreme distances the
foundation wanted to see if the same
could be said for the Great White Wave
after pouring several liters of animal
blood into the water of an affected area
they found that a Great White Wave
regularly manifested within 2 minutes
crashing down and devouring the affected
blood however an extension of this
experiment found an alarming result the
same amount of human blood attracted a
Great White Wave in under 60 seconds
even a small amount of human blood
attracted a Great White Wave
significantly faster than a large amount
of animal blood interestingly
non-anomalous great white sharks will
rarely ever attack humans on purpose
whenever they do it's often because they
mistook a swimming or surfing human for
a seal their natural prey you'll often
find that most shark attack victims are
only bitten once a common shark behavior
known as a testing bite once the shark
realizes that it isn't eating a seal it
will quickly move along yes this
probably won't make the person with a
shark bite taken out of them feel any
better but the shark didn't truly want
to eat them great white Waves by
contrast enjoy eating humans
significantly more than animals but that
doesn't mean they won't eat all kinds of
animals several Maritime birds were
eaten by a great white wave when they
flew in front of the wave that was over
4 M tall we suppose the Great White Wave
has never heard the salt the old Sea Dog
tale that it's bad luck to kill a
seabird the foundation discovered a few
useful things from their experiments if
you want to avoid getting eaten by the
Great White Wave you should avoid
getting into the water if you're
suffering from any kind of injury
wounded people are four times as likely
to be the victims of attacks with the
Great White Wave manifesting in less
than 60 seconds you can also improve
your chances of surviving by following
Sam Neil's advice from Jurassic Park
don't move a muscle movement especially
panicked thrashing has a tendency to
lure this unique aquatic Predator into
your vicinity But Here Comes the
disappointing part other than staying in
a landlock area there's basically
nothing else you can do in order to stop
a Great White Wave event weapons have
proven completely ineffective with the
bullets of even the highest caliber
weapons simply disappearing into the
wall of water stealth Beyond avoiding
movement is also ineffective no attempt
to camouflage the smell of humans has
been effective in in helping them evade
the detection of the Great White Wave
you can probably imagine how many
unfortunate DCL classes got devoured in
the process of finding that one out the
Great White Wave is a disturbing
reminder that perhaps we shouldn't worry
about what lurks in the deep ocean when
nothing has a greater capacity to
destroy us than the unimaginable power
of the ocean itself water the Wellspring
of Life we've dealt with a number of
anomalous water sources on this channel
like CP 006 the much sought after
Fountain of Youth or the terrifying SCP
3280 where murderous water threatens to
destroy the entire world but we've never
seen anomalous water that behaves quite
like this before in many of the legends
of King Arthur the sword of Excalibur is
presented to him by the mystical Lady of
the Lake this lady emerges from the
depths of the water gifting Arthur with
the enchanted sword it's an incredible
if possible image a woman appearing from
within the lake rising up from the
bottom and breaking through the surface
it's safe to say that none of us have
ever seen anything quite like it well at
least most of us haven't in a small
unnamed English Village there was a
young woman who set out on a
particularly lovely warm spring day to
take a swim in a nearby lake while
waiting in the water enjoying the
sunlight and the gentle breeze on her
skin she saw a strange Ripple ghost
across the surface surface she stopped
her swimming staring at the motion she
expected to spot a fish or some other
aquatic creature instead the water
itself began to rise up Gathering and
forming into a shape before her eyes it
was impossible and yet here it was
happening she pinched herself and found
that she was definitely awake as the
water transformed into the shape of a
human woman it turned to look at her
shimmering eyes finding hers and liquid
lips forming into a warm inviting smile
though this being was shocking to see it
clearly meant her no harm it raised a
translucent arm and gave her a small
wave as if to welcome her to its home
the young woman approached this Lady of
the Lake reaching out her own hand of
Flesh and bone to touch this Impossible
Creature just as her fingertips reached
the water woman's Z the figure dissolved
back into the lake with a splash the
young woman ran home telling anyone who
would listen about the incredible thing
she had seen that day of course no one
believed her that is until word of her
sighting reached the only people who
might take her claim seriously the SCP
Foundation they sent operatives to the
lake where they managed to capture the
shape-shifting entity dwelling there SCP
054 also known as the water nymph is a
being made up entirely of water with an
average volume of 90 L when it is out of
a body of water the being tends to adopt
the appearance of a humanoid
though it is capable of taking on a
variety of other shapes including other
humanoids animals and various inanimate
objects The Entity is also capable of
shedding its form and effectively
disappearing into a given body of water
in order to avoid shrinking or possibly
disappearing entirely from evaporation
SCP 054 is required to return to a
larger body of water studies of samples
taken from the entity's body or its
version of a body revealed that it is
made up of ordinary water there is no
apparent reason for its ability to move
and no thermal electromagnetic
biological or Supernatural anomalies
were detected the research team could
not determine what might make this water
alive and sentient and the nature of its
unusual properties is uncertain to this
day when SCP 054 was first brought into
containment at site 08 it displayed
surprisingly congenial and curious
Behavior often walking around outside of
the water and taking turns mimicking the
shapes of various staff and scientists
that spoke to it its demeanor began to
shift towards suspicion and aggression
however following a series of
experiments and an incident involving
the research staff the first experiment
conducted on SCP 054 sought to determine
what would happen if the entity was
denied access to any fresh water water
was drained from the fountain holding it
leaving only enough water for it to form
a humanoid shape but no additional water
in the Basin to compensate for the
effects of evaporation over time SCP 054
became visibly frustrated as the water
was being drained out of its enclosure
for the next few days it
enthusiastically greeted anyone who
entered its containment facility
attempting to use a report and sense of
familiarity to convince the person to
provide it with more water after it
realized that this approach had no
impact on the amount of water in its
Fountain it became distant and even cold
to anyone who attempted to speak to it
054 only became friendly again once the
water in its Fountain was restored to a
pre-experiment level next the research
team opted to test SCP 054 reaction to
extreme temperatures particularly
extreme cold the temperature of the
containment facility was slowly dropped
until the room fell below the freezing
point of water as the temperature
dropped 054 became sluggish and
exhausted it lost its ability to shift
between forms remaining locked in its
preferred humanoid female shape its
movement slowed more and more as the
room grew colder until the entity was
completely frozen solid portions of the
ice were chipped off and studied
revealing the crystals were identical to
those of ordinary ice after the Sub-Zero
testing the research team decided to
take things to the other end of the
spectrum and test the effects of heat on
SCP 054 the subject was placed in a tank
outfitted with heating equipment and its
temperature was slowly raised over the
course of several minutes when the water
reached a temperature of 95° the
entity's behavior became frenetic and
aggressive it pounded on the glass walls
of the tank and attempted to break
through the lid in a desperate bid for
escape until the temperature was
returned to a comfortable level after
the extreme temperature experiments the
previous calm and Cooperative nature of
SCP 054 was nowhere to be found the
subject displayed increased suspicion of
the research team and would fight back
whenever it was removed from its
Fountain and taken to a lab for
experimentation in spite of this new
found resistance the team decided to
continue their experiments as planned
hoping that the entity would return to
its formerly do self over time next Dr
Cesc the acting head of the research
team conducted a study involving SCP 054
memory and ability to be conditioned The
Entity was presented with a series of
increasingly complex mazes and puzzles
when it failed to comply with the
experiment or solved a puzzle
incorrectly The Entity was punished with
an electrical shock or the release of
silica gel into its body both of these
options seemed to cause it a great deal
of pain and distress and it was eager to
avoid fur F exposure to them SCP 054
displayed impressive learning and
problem solving capabilities revealing
it is likely much more intelligent than
it was first presumed to be Dr cesal
observing the experiments and with the
effectiveness of his somewhat unsavory
motivational techniques equipped to his
research assistant that they would have
it trained to fetch in no time after
several days of these experiments and
repeated use of both the silica gel and
electrical shocks the entity's progress
slowed down considerably and it became
visibly exhausted it was removed from
the lab for a 48-hour rest period before
experimentation was resumed yet again
this time Dr cesco planned to expose SCP
054 water source to various levels of
acids and bases in order to test its
homeostatic capabilities beginning with
a5m solution of hydrochloric acid prior
to conducting the experiment Dr cesal
noted I have no idea what will happen
but if this thing incorporates
homeostatic mechanisms like I suspect
zvi should get some insight into how it
maintains its form he also noted that
SCP 054 Behavior was becoming
increasingly erratic but made the
decision to continue with the experiment
as planned SCP 054 displayed a now
familiar reluctance when it was removed
from its containment chamber and taken
to the lab it thrashed around in the
fountain splashing researchers with
water and retreated from them as they
approached in spite of its efforts
however it was removed from its Fountain
and placed in the experimental tank the
solution of hydrochloric acid was then
dripped into the tank and then all hell
broke loose as soon as the acid touched
the surface of its water SCP 054 became
incredibly distressed it Formed into the
shape of a human face eyes wide mouth
open in a Silent Scream Of Rage and pain
the water churned so aggressively that
the lid of the tank was shaken loose
allowing it to escape the boundaries of
its containment the water formed into
two large hands which shot out of the
tank and grabb the two nearest
researchers pulling them into the water
and exposing their skin to the acid now
present there as the men scrambled to
drag themselves back out of the tank and
their colleagues were busy helping them
SCP 054 took on its usual humanoid form
and ran for the door it then collapsed
into a puddle slipped under the crack in
the bottom of the door and made its way
down the hall it was apprehended roughly
10 minutes after its Escape by a team of
guards who froze it using canisters of
liquid nitrogen and then carried its icy
body back to the containment fac
facility the two researchers who had
been pulled into the tank experienced
chemical burns on their skin as well as
significant mental distress they were
given immediate medical attention and
placed on a leave of absence and all
experimentation on SCP 054 was suspended
until further notice at the
recommendation of Dr ccll 04's object
class was changed to uclid SCP 054 is
currently contained in a watertight
isolation room fitted with climate
control equipment a beautiful
intricately designed Fountain has been
placed in the center of the containment
room filled with fresh spring water in
order to accommodate the entities
environmental needs all maintenance
workers assigned to the area must wear
NBC suits while inside and must spend 10
minutes isolated in a drying room After
exiting before they are permitted to
return to the rest of the facility if
054 breaches containment the area must
be evacuated and the containment chamber
will be filled with liquid nitrogen in
order to freeze its water solid as The
Entity is highly sensitive to the
conditions of the water that houses it
chemical levels and volume of the water
in the fountain must be monitored on a
regular basis and kept at optimal levels
for the health of SCP 054 during the
course of its containment following the
incident around the acid base
incorporation experiment 054 has
developed a distrust of men as the
researchers handling that experiment
were primarily male in order to prevent
future incidents and keep SCP 054 calm
no male staff are to be assigned to the
team monitoring its containment unit
because 5 years have passed since the
last incident involving SCP 054 its
object class has been changed from uclid
to safe on the recommendation of the
lead researcher assigned to its case of
course caution should still be exercise
while interacting with the entity this
is the SCP Foundation after all and just
because a moderate amount of water is
good for you doesn't mean you can't
still drown experimentation on SCP 054
has resumed though this time its
boundaries are being honored and it is
allowed adequate time to rest and
recuperate between experiments all use
of punishment in order to motivate The
Entity has been suspended as it has
shown itself to be more than willing to
cooperate if it is treated with respect
like all of us it responds far better to
kindness than it does to fear and
intimidation it doesn't just take on the
appearance of a person it has thoughts
feelings and the urge to defend itself
when threatened so think twice next time
you find yourself swimming in a random
body of water you should be mindful of
what might be living in there not just
of the fish the algae and the tiny water
bugs but of the invisible intelligent
impossible creatures that might be
swimming in there with you or even make
up the very water itself it was just a
job you were meant to be mopping floors
and cleaning toilets at the Johnston
labs and pharmaceuticals Research Center
for minimum wage and you were happy
about it grateful for any kind of
employment you didn't even know know
that the company signing your checks was
the SCP Foundation an organization
dedicated to securing and containing
anomalies and protecting Humanity from
their negative effects at any cost and
today you're going to find out exactly
how steep that cost can be the Johnston
labs and pharmaceuticals Research Center
isn't actually a research center at all
it's a foundation front business with a
building solely dedicated to the
containment of a single anomaly SCP
3280 but again you're just the janitor
it's not like they would bother telling
you what's being contained here if it
breaks out you won't even know what's
killing you until it's too late it
begins like most classic horror stories
on a dark and stormy night you're
mopping up a silent hallway whistling a
little tune to yourself when rain starts
hammering down on the window next to you
not long after you see a bolt of
lightning split the distant Sky followed
by by an immense Thunder crack soon
after you hear screaming and panicking
From Below frantic footsteps then the
flashing lights and Sirens you think
back to your employee orientation these
flashing lights and wailing Sirens can
only mean one thing Containment Breach
you run for it not even knowing what
you're running from you bring your mop
and bucket with you perhaps just out of
habit you seek refuge in the only place
in the facility that truly seems to
belong to you you the broom closet the
alarm blares as you lock yourself in the
closet you're shaking with Terror and
can hear the screaming of your
colleagues you hear more noises running
scrambling a wet dripping sound gunshots
and then silence all this time you can't
help but wonder why isn't anybody coming
to help us after a while the only thing
you can hear is the rain and the distant
Thunder it's been hours you've only
maned managed to Stave off dehydration
by drinking the filthy water from the
mop sink but at least it seems like the
chaos outside has died down carefully
you open the door and peek out of the
closet Darkness but no detectable
movement now as your chance and you make
a break for it creeping down the hall
the dark hallway is suddenly lit up by
lightning and you can see that there are
bodies everywhere you step over the
corpse of Dr Kone one of the few
scientists working here who actually
knew your name if you can make it to the
security office you might be able to
radio for help or maybe access a
computer terminal on the way to the
office you hear another horrific scream
start to echo through the complex before
it's cut off by a Thunderclap you have
to ignore it though and push on when you
enter the security room you see that the
head security officer Nicholls is
already dead his body has been cut open
from neck to groin gutted the anomaly
whatever it it is has already been here
you access the computer terminal and
open the file for SCP
3280 you're warned that as janitorial
staff you have level zero clearance and
as a result information will be omitted
from the files you access it doesn't
matter you press on and open up the file
both the object class and the
description have been redacted you can
only see the special containment
procedures they dictate that 3280 is to
remain contained at the Johnston labs
and Pharmaceuticals Research Center
until long-term containment procedures
can be drawn up if the entity ever
reaches Beyond subl 2 the facility
enters full lockdown mode not even
information is allowed in or out of the
facility as this could result in an XK
Class end of the world scenario in other
words nobody is coming to save you the
only other information on the page is a
picture of a lightning storm much like
the one you find yourself in right now
now lightning flashes in the hall you
Dart around paranoid knowing the anomaly
could be anywhere all you can hear now
is the quiet drip drip drip of blood
coming from the body of security officer
Nicholls whatever this thing had done to
him looked painful you try to remember
him as he was in life and then a
revelation hits you a security officer
probably has a lot better clearance than
a janitor you feel around Nicholls
mutilated torso until you find his key
card thankfully Nichols was the kind of
guy who' write his password on the
underside of this card so he wouldn't
forget it you easily gain access to the
foundation servers with his login
credentials you now have level two
security clearance the terminal gives
you the option to view security footage
taken throughout the site you're given
access to every camera still working
after the Containment Breach and the
subsequent Carnage you select the camera
feed for the second floor Barracks there
you see researcher Jensen hanging from a
makeshift new attached to his bunk
there's a puddle underneath his corpse
you access the feed from the second
floor east Wing there you see Dr Emanuel
stumbling down a dark Corridor his
movements are oddly listless like he's
in a trance suddenly there's another
flash of lightning and a crack of
thunder Dr Emanuel clutches his gut in
pain and crumples to the floor you
access the camera feed from the first
floor entrance it seems that the whole
area is flooded is this because of the
storm in a panic many lower tier staff
members had tried to escape defying the
lockdown protocols and the special
containment procedures now they're
floating face down in the water all dead
you access the camera feed from sublevel
2 and see another corpse lying in the
corner he's wearing an orange jumpsuit
d-class no idea why he was down there
the only other notable thing in the
basement was a burst pipe leaking and
spraying more water everywhere with
trembling fingers you select the camera
feed for the first floor cafeteria the
whole room is practically underwater the
only evidence of the massacre that must
have taken place are the fragments of
clothing floating on the surface of the
water that and the fleshy pink slurry
forming at the bottom of the windows it
reminds you of the gooey meat runoff in
chicken nugget factories you close your
eyes and try to Center yourself it's
violent chaos looking at more of it
isn't getting you anywhere instead you
put those new level two security access
credentials to good use and hop back
onto the file for SCP 3280 you think to
yourself there has to be something I can
use on here but even as you wait for the
file to load some part of you knows that
time is running out for you perhaps it's
the stress or the fear or the filthy mop
water you drank but you're feeling the
pressures start to mount physically your
stomach is beginning to ache you can see
blurry shapes moving in the corners of
your eyes it's getting harder to focus
your vision and harder still to quiet
the terrified voices in your mind but
you can't get up not without knowing
what is doing this to you the
containment class for SCP 3280 is now
Declassified uclid and once more the
special containment procedures have
altered too they now explain that every
week a new member of d-class personnel
is to be deposited into the entity's
layer in suev 2 through Subterranean
access point gamma the d-class or more
accurately the sacrifices are to be told
lies about why exactly they need to
descend to the lowest point in the
facility they're even given a working
flashlight and a defensive night stick
to create the illusion that the
foundation expects them to ever return
from the depths little do they know they
also have a tiny transmitter sewn into
their jumpsuit this broadcasts a
frequency that will attract an eager SCP
32 80 to the DCL class's location like a
dinnerbell only it can hear the file
specifies that SCP 3280 always prefers
live prey well at least that explains
the dead d-class in sublevel 2 you think
hoping that it will somehow overwhelm
the dizziness you're feeling or the
nagging pain in your gut you read on
somehow the file's tone becomes even
more severe it says that failure to
maintain the containment of SCP 3280
will not only trigger a lot lock down it
will always call in the intervention of
two different mobile task forces MTF
Iota 12 the silencers and to 4 also
known as water water everywhere if 12
hours pass from the point of initial
Containment Breach and the 05 Council
hasn't been given the all clear signal
by one of these teams preparation Begins
for an imminent XK Class end of the
world scenario just reading the words
sends you into a cold sweat end of the
world what on Earth is this creature
finally you reach the description you
get to find out what this horrifying
entity actually is but the last thing
you expect is the first sentence in the
file to read SCP 3280 is a Sapient
entity composed of a fluid physically
identical to water capable of traveling
roughly 2 and 1/2 km per hour it's water
it's literally a living thinking blob of
water as you read on the concerning
details pile up any water that the
anomalous SCP 3280 water touches it
integrates it into its own Mass but
anytime water is separated from this
Mass it remains anomalous and continues
to act independently when the creature
was first discovered it was a mere 66.4
l in volume now it's around
2500 the water infected by SCP 3280 is
hostile to all humans and not just in a
defensive manner SCP 32 280 will
actively seek out human prey and when it
finds them it forces its mass into any
available body orifice including the
victim's pores this can happen in such a
subtle manner that you may not even
notice yourself being infiltrated but
below this the file has a list of
symptoms for those experiencing 30280
infiltration loss of motor control
weakening of the murcian reflex visual
hallucinations and abdominal pain as you
read the words your stomach gives
another painful churn almost like
something is moving around inside of you
it's all coming together you read on the
file states that SCP 3280 is so
difficult to contain because it exhibits
claustrophobic Tendencies anytime it's
placed inside a container whether
organic or inorganic it escapes with
pressurized water jets that travel at
over 255 mes hour if the water is inside
a human it may literally explode out of
them kill King them in the process your
jittering eyes turned to the gutted body
of security officer Nicholls it all
makes sense now everything is becoming
clearer as the pain in your stomach
builds in its intensity the file goes on
to say that if SCP 3280 escapes sublevel
2 it may be impossible to contain again
if 3280 ever escaped the site proper it
would indeed cause an XK Class end of
the world scenario to unfold as 3280
merged with our water cycle and
destroyed all of Humanity on a global
scale it would become truly impossible
for anyone to escape you can't read
anymore the pain in your stomach is
unbearable you jerk from your seat and
stumble out into the Hall doubled over
in agony you can feel it pulsing in
there fighting its way out it must have
gotten in through the filthy mop water
you were drinking you didn't even know
it but your fate has been sealed for
hours you've been a dead man walking the
hum of pain builds in your ears and
renders you almost death all you can
hear is the pattern of rain and distant
Thunder you collapse against the glass
feeling the coolness of it against the
skin of your face and in that moment you
see the water droplets on the window
pane reverse Direction they're
slithering up the glass towards your
face in defiance of gravity then you
realize it's all over and not just for
you SCP 3280 has escaped it's out there
and it's going to drown the entire world
as you collapse to your knees and
prepare to be torn apart from the inside
your final thought is that at least you
won't be alive to see it you're right in
the middle of one of the hottest Summers
on record the days are filled with
bright scorching sun and Searing heat
and you've been laying around with your
air conditioning on full blast just to
try and cool yourself off sadly it's not
really working and the heat is becoming
way too much much but then you remember
there's this married couple that lives
near you with no kids and they happen to
have a swimming pool in their yard
normally they keep to themselves they'd
never let you use their pool but they've
gone out of town for a few days besides
the heat is killing you you're sure that
the neighbors wouldn't mind if you just
took a quick dip as long as you clean up
after yourself they probably wouldn't
even notice you were even there
cautiously you make your way to their
house it's an unremarkable Place similar
to most of the other houses in this
suburb of New Mexico after checking that
there's nobody else around you climb the
2 m High cinder block wall that stands
around the back Garden as you drop to
your feet sweaty and panting from the
unrelenting summer heat you see it the
pool your salvation water never looks so
appealing immediately you step Barefoot
across the sunscorch tiles and sit on
the edge legs in the water it's cool and
refreshing perfect for a day as hot as
today you're already changed in wearing
your swim trunks so it doesn't take long
for you to paddle out to the middle of
the pool letting that chilled clean
water cool you off as you're taking a
dip you notice the pool's Jets turning
on automatically it's a little bit odd
but you shrug it off that couple clearly
shelled out for a pool with a lot of
fancy bells and whistles but extra
features aren't why you're here you came
because if you didn't then you could
have melt melted under all that sunlight
floating on the surface of the water you
relax with your arms behind your head
and close your eyes you don't have time
to realize that coming here was a
mistake instead you start to feel
relaxed so calm so tranquil you're one
with the water around you now it's
almost as though you could just
disappear so you do the police never
find any trace of you everyone else
simply writes it on off as a random
disappearance there's not even so much
as a scrap of your body left in the pool
just the clear clean water why because
the swimming pool you decided to take a
cooling dip in wasn't an ordinary pool
it was SCP 242 but don't worry you won't
be the last to make that costly mistake
what you didn't know is that the married
couple who live in that house are
secretly a pair of SCP Foundation
doctors the house isn't even there s the
foundation procured it after the former
owner a retired out ofate landlord
strangely vanished he had been
struggling to find anyone to rent the
place so he eventually decided to give
up on the property game and move in
there himself after 3 days he was never
seen again now that house has only one
rule that must be followed above all
else do not swim in the pool SCP 242 is
at least to the untrained eye just an
average swimming pool a decent 9 m in
length 4 and 1/2 wide and it holds
around 53,000 L of sterile pool water
like we mentioned before it's even got
some Nifty features like water jets a
dual waterfall and a built-in vacuum
unit for sucking out any impurities and
we mean any impurities you see SCP 242
does go by another name the
self-cleaning pool and while that might
not sound as for boating or dramatic as
the Scarlet king or the wendigo skull or
the horrifying nasty dude of ultimate
Badness okay we made that last one up we
can assure you that you don't ever want
to suffer the fate of taking a swim in
this pool there was an incident a while
ago recorded by the foundation through a
secret hidden camera the house where SCP
242 can be found had been left vacant
for a time and once again some
opportunists decided to take advantage
of the empty swimming pool this time it
was was a couple a man and a woman in
their early 20s they climbed up the back
wall undressed and even stole a couple
of plastic inflatable rafts from a shed
in The house's backyard the water jets
switched themselves on startling the
girl but her boyfriend told her not to
worry the filter to clean the pool was
probably just on an automatic timer
right surely it wouldn't have been
anything to worry about after swimming
together for around 24 minutes the
couple both agreed that the water felt
warm tingly even both of them climbed
onto their rafts eventually falling
asleep while still holding each other's
hands but almost half an hour after the
Jets had started something caused the
two rafts to burst the couple awoke
startled by the loud pop of the
splitting Inflatables and being plunged
back into the water the pool around them
immediately began frothing violently and
deep red streams of blood swirling
through the water as the couple screamed
in fear and Agony both of them tried to
desperately swim to the edge hoping to
leave the pool and get to safety but
unfortunately that plan didn't work
before they could reach the edge the man
and the wom were Pulled Under the
surface of the Raging Water their limbs
thrashing as they still tried in vain to
escape eventually they vanished under
the Crimson bloody water the frothing
slowly began to calm and the red in the
pool dissipated once again becoming
clear after 48 seconds the couple were
never seen again and a cover story was
leaked to the Press by the SCP
Foundation 2 weeks after they went
missing according to them the pair had
eloped together somewhere in Mexico if
only that sounds a lot nicer than what
actually happened to them so this
swimming pool clearly has some anomalous
properties that much is obvious but what
exactly are those properties how exactly
does SCP 242 work is it an
interdimensional Gateway that drags
people to a nasty alternate universe if
they spend too long swimming in it or is
the swimming pool itself a sentient
carnivorous creature that lures humans
in only to devour them maybe the water
is teeming with invisible flesh eating
piranhas that can strip the meat from
the bone in a matter of seconds well
good guesses all around but actually
it's none of these it's unclear what
causes the pool's anomalous effects it
could be a property that is completely
unique to the water contained in SCP 242
or maybe it's down to the exact shape
and measurements of the pool itself it
could even be a combination of both but
whatever the cause the result is always
the same when any object substance or
even living organism is placed in SCP
242 it will be entirely Rewritten on a
molecular level the genetic and atomic
structure will fall apart and the
subject will be transmuted into sterile
water in fact not just clean water but
water that remains sterile even when
removed from the pool if you took a cup
C of SCP 242s water and mix something
like food coloring into it the food
coloring would not be absorbed into the
water instead staying as one non-missile
bubble this process doesn't happen
instantly though it can vary depending
on how contaminated or complex the
substance placed in SCP 242 is for
example water sampled from a nearby
River was sterilized and purified by the
pool in about 7 minutes a sample of
stagnant pond water riddled with various
diseases and germs took 11 minutes
longer what about 50,000 L of colar well
that one took a little longer 12 long
days to be exact but was still turned
into pure sterile water and as for a
living human being maybe ask that couple
that took a dip in the self-cleaning
pool the foundation is naturally
fascinated with the pool and after
extensive examination they have
determined that SCP 242 doesn't seem to
have been intentionally designed for the
specific anomalous function it performs
the components of SCP 242 beyond the
pool itself the filter the vacuum the
pipes none of these parts nor anything
about the swimming pool's design appear
to be responsible for disintegrating
matter until only water remains you
might have noticed that in the case of
the ill- fated couple who took a swim in
SCP 242 the water jets and waterfall
features switch themselves on
automatically before the pair's Grim
demise somehow these features are able
to activate without the need for
electricity as disconnecting the pool
from a power source will not stop the
Jets and waterfall from coming on once a
nonwater substance is placed into SCP
242 the same goes for the pool vacuum
which apparently cannot be jammed or
malfunction even when the bottom of the
pool is a wash with viscous liquids like
that colar the vacuum will continue to
operate as normal scrubbing away at the
floor of SCP 242 the one part of the
self-cleaning pool that doesn't work as
you would expect is the water filtration
system there is never any water being
cycled into the pool nor out of it as a
matter of fact the pipes connecting to
the filtration system have all been
removed then again who needs a
filtration system when your backyard
swimming pool can just spontaneously
reduce anything to clean water but that
raises another frightening thought
everything that the pool has ever taken
and converted is still in there
animals objects people just swimming
around you perhaps if they could still
think they'd scream and shout and tell
you to get away to run while you still
can but the second your skin touches the
water you're destined to be with them
forever and ever and ever it's enough to
send a liquid chill down your spine okay
so if it's not the actual physical pool
that causes these anomalous effects that
must mean it's something in the water
right perhaps some microscopic flesh
devouring microbe or some ancient curse
that was placed on the water before it
was used to fill up the pool surely if
you took a cup of water out of SCP 242
it would still break down structures on
a molecular level leaving only more
sterile water while the researchers
working at the SCP Foundation thought
much of the same and conducted a series
of tests to determine the exact
properties of SCP 242s water one test
involves submerging two d-class test
subjects each wearing an atmospheric
dive suit into SCP 242 the goal was to
determine if it was safe to consume the
water from SCP 242 while both inside and
outside of the pool test subject a was
lowered into the water and instructed to
drink from a metal straw by their mouth
the eye pieces of their goggles were
blacked out so they couldn't see what
they were drinking from subject B filled
a barrel with the same water from SCP
242 and then was made to put on an
atmospheric dive suit but instructed to
stay out of the pool test subject a was
told to drink directly from the pool
remarking that the water was warm and
had a bit of a noticeable chemical
aftertaste but was otherwise normal then
test subject B drank some of the same
water from the barrel apparently it was
cool and tasted of well nothing just
like water usually does after a moment
more of drink subject a began belching
finding that they had uncontrollable gas
the water had begun to feel warmer
stinging the subject's mouth while for
subject B the water from the barrel
stayed cool and refreshing the
foundation doctors overseeing the
experiment instructed test subject a to
keep drinking which they did until it
felt even hotter to The Taste one of the
DCL class's fillings even fell out and
eventually the structural Integrity of
subject A's dive suit failed presumably
disintegrated by the water from SCP 242
after a few muffled screams and gurgling
noises test subject a wasn't heard from
again and we can all probably guess why
as for subject B they kept drinking from
the barrel suffering no adverse effects
even after 17 long hours there were no
noticeable psychological or physical
changes even their urine showed no
traces of abnormality the water from SCP
242 left in the barrel evaporated as
normal leaving behind no residue or any
indicator as to why taking the water out
of the pool made it safer to drink than
the same water in the pool perhaps the
moral of the story is to just be careful
where you choose to take a swim
otherwise it could be your last
Commander McGrath one of the most
influential members of mobile task force
Alpha One better known as the red right
hand had been summoned by his Masters
for one of the most important missions
of his life it was so Above Top Secret
even he would likely need to undergo
amnestic treatment once he'd seen the
job through it comes with the territory
when you're dealing with SCP
006 the red right hand is no ordinary
mobile task force either they were the
personal enforcers of the 05 Council the
13 most powerful members of the SCP
Foundation and by extension some of the
most powerful human beings on Earth
Commander McGrath stood before the
assembled Council trying to suppress the
Tremors of fear and awe running through
him he'd gone toe-to-toe with a GP 076
AEL one of the finest humanoid Warriors
ever known during one of his many
containment breaches he led strike
forces after a fleeing SCP 682 the heart
to destroy reptile after it escaped its
acid tank and began charging towards the
nearest populated area intent on causing
Mass death he'd personally taken out
more people than you've probably ever
met all at the behest of his foundation
superiors and yet standing right here
before them he could couldn't help feel
a twinge of deep Terror it was like
staring right into the face of God and
waiting for it to Blink with his
well-honed military observation skills
he noted that 0 5-2 wasn't among the
council this time but he knew better
than to ask why he was employed to take
orders not to ask questions and this
time his orders were something special
he wasn't given any more information
than this McGrath we need you to lead an
elite team to a Sten and on the double
procedure 006 is now in effect you know
what to do McGrath nodded he'd been
prepared for this day his predecessor
Commander Richards had only needed to
enact procedure 006 once in his long and
storyed career with the red right hand
it was truly a once- in a-lifetime
assignment and now the torch had been
passed to him the only question was
whether he'd be up to the task but
McGrath didn't have time to ponder on
this question time was was of the
essence first he needed to assemble a
team small but focused loyal men who'd
Keep Their Heads down complete the
mission and take the Forbidden Knowledge
no further than the bounds of said
Mission McGrath selected three
operatives Bennett dagio and Stewart all
of whom had proven valuable Assets in
Prior missions they would be the ones to
accompany him on this most valuable and
secretive of directives procedure
006 but before they could execute the
mission itself they needed to be trained
briefed and fitted with the proper
equipment for Mission this sensitive and
dealing with an anomaly as deadly as SCP
006 they needed to wear modified class 6
B and C suits these are the ultimate
total exclusion hazmat suits designed
specifically by the SCP Foundation they
offered such a degree of protection that
they made Regular hazmat suits look like
bikinis Commander McGrath actually knew
very little about SCP 00
and how it worked like many of the more
top secret anomalies contained by the
foundation only the 05 Council
understood the full scope of it everyone
below them were only told the specific
fragments of information they needed to
do their job after all filling your head
with the wrong kinds of knowledge can
get your memory wiped or worse at the
SCP Foundation SCP 006 as far as
Commander McGrath knew was the more
traditional kind of toxic he'd been
briefed using the CP 006b info pack a
heavily redacted description of SCP
006 safe class liquid in nature but one
of the most toxic substances known to
man it made Mercury and uranium look
like a glass of mineral water and more
dangerous still if someone came into
contact with even the tiniest quantity
of SCP 006s liquids they would not only
be marked for certain death they would
also become a vector for transmission a
very veritable plague rat a walking
danger to all mankind that's why the
class 6 BNC suits needed to be tested
McGrath Bennett dagio and Stuart suited
up in a secure foundation training
facility and fully submerged themselves
in a training pool this was how they
made sure that there were no
vulnerabilities in the suits if any
bubbles were generated it meant there
was a leak and if there was a leak then
the person wearing the defective suit
was as good as dead when they reached
reached the real
006 lucky for them no leaks they were
ready to proceed to the next stage of
the mission making their way to arren
Russia where SCP 006 was contained the
pressure was on with the council growing
more impatient by the moment so they
needed to make the journey immediately
every minute counted and Commander
McGrath was painfully aware of the time
slipping away though he couldn't
possibly fathom why they need a toxic
chemical like this with such urgency
they made their journey in a covert
cargo plane it was beyond important to
keep all Foundation activity around SCP
006 Under Wraps a number of groups of
Interest cells were active in the area
including the Church of the broken God
and the Serpent's hand and if ever the
dreaded chaos Insurgency caught wind of
SCP 00 6's existence and triangulated
its location the damage it could do
would be unprecedented that's why nobody
but the 05 council could truly be
trusted with this almost sacred
knowledge when they touched down in
estren they met with a foundation
Courier who would take them on the final
leg of their Journey to the foundation
site roughly 60 km west of the Town
McGrath and his team had no idea what
they were headed towards or the insane
history of the land they traversed all
because of SCP
006 the foundation had first become
aware of the anomaly back during the
19th century but were unable to gain
control of it until until
1991 due to it being fiercely guarded by
A procession of territorial Russian
rulers the blood of hundreds of
thousands had been spilled on this land
in the historic Wars and conflicts over
SCP
006 so many had wasted their entire
lives unsuccessfully trying to find it
during the several hour car trip to the
site Commander mcrath had no idea of the
true value of the anomaly he and his
small team were heading towards but he
would in time though an innocent would
have to die first The Courier dropped
the four operatives off outside an
abandoned chemical plant in the sticks
far from what anyone would call
civilization it was the kind of
industrial Decay you could expect in the
bad lands of rural Russia a huge complex
weathered and broken by time but what
the untrained Observer wouldn't realize
is that the plant was actually full of
heavily trained and even more heavily
armed Foundation security personnel as
McGrath team approached the building
they had no less than eight sniper
rifles pointed at them from various
Vantage points within the plant just to
be safe the foundation couldn't afford
to take any chances with SCP
006 they arrived at the gate and
provided their clearance credentials
they were envoys here on behalf of the
05 Council themselves and if they
weren't allowed to complete their
mission then the 006 Personnel would
have the death of a council member on
their hands with that the team was given
a free pass into the site under close
observation anyone seeking to interface
SCP 006 was forced to do so under almost
microscopic scrutiny even when inside
the building McGrath and his men needed
to pass multiple secure checkpoints
throughout the Halls each time restating
their security credentials eventually
they reached a different section of the
building for boating anomalous hallways
gave way to what seemed like a mix of a
garden and a jungle but the plants were
different the trees the shrubs even the
weeds were unlike anything members of
the team had ever seen before it was
like stepping into an alien world or
perhaps this world but as it was a few
million years prior it was terrifying
and wondrous they suited up in their
class 6 BNC suits fearing Airborne
contaminants from SCP 006 before
proceeding further they walk through
this new Jungle being watched at every
turn by security cam and Personnel
posted throughout this overgrown portion
of the facility it didn't take long for
them to reach their destination the
legendary SCP
006 a small natural spring jutting out
of a rock surrounded by Rich Emerald
grass it looked more like a nice place
to have a picnic than a dangerous and
highly secretive anomaly but McGrath
wasn't paid to question things only to
carry out procedure
006 the only object they had with them
was the quad sealant container an ultra
secure liquid containment unit
specifically designed for safely
transporting samples of SCP z06's water
between sights the team members
descended into the spring and began
filling up the container it was
nerve-racking knowing the stakes of
their mission and knowing that they were
submerged in such a deadly substance but
they had a job to do and they were going
to do it come hell or high water they
filled the containment unit but sadly
for McGrath and his team the mission
wouldn't be entirely without casualty a
single bubble Rose from the leg of
Stuart's suit he was a good MTF
operative but the youngest and least
experienced member of the team his suit
must have somehow been damaged during
Transit and now he was compromised he
shared a haunting glance with McGrath
and his fellow team members knowing that
his part of the mission and his life was
about to come to a Swift and violent end
alarms rang out across the facility
a huge team of armed operatives all
wearing class 6 BNC suits charged into
the room Stuart was grabbed and
manhandled out of the 006 spring while
his fellow team members sealed the
containment unit and continued their
mission there was no time to stop rest
or mourn completing the mission was the
absolute priority if McGrath understood
the protocol as well as he thought he
did Stewart would be dragged into a
secure room by the site staff and locked
in with a blast door he would look down
and notice the floor below below him was
a metal grate caked with Ash his last
thoughts as the incinerator launches its
Flames into action would strangely be
the fact that he was feeling the
healthiest he'd been in years but that
wouldn't stop the sudden furnace around
him from decimating his body and leaving
little more than Ash and charred bones
over a decade of loyal MTF service ended
in an instant Stewart would have been
terminated according to orders from the
top it was all that could be done for
those afflicted by a SCP 00 6 a mercy
really if they were to be believed
McGrath and his team soldiered on after
retrieving the sample they were hurried
back into their Inception point one of
the many classified bases occupied by
the 05 council members while dagio and
Bennett were ushered off to be given
amnestic treatment McGrath would
personally get to see the containment
unit and its Precious Cargo make the
final leg of the journey he was going to
be granted access
25-2 the person this had all been in
service of Commander McGrath approached
the secure quarters of the council
member escorted by a bevy of heavily
armed security Personnel the doors open
and he saw her there
McGrath entered the room holding the
containment unit she beckoned him closer
until he was close enough for her to
take the containment unit from him with
scarred Trembling Hands McGrath watched
in horror as she disengaged the lid and
swigged down the entirety of its
contents but wasn't the water toxic he
thought McGrath had been fed the same
lie as everybody else the foundation
didn't keep 006 such a well-guarded
secret because it was capable of
bringing death quite the opposite in
fact all Commander McGrath could do was
stare a struck as the years seemed to
fall from
05-25-18
40s it was a complete and total
transformation the liquid of SCP 006 has
a plethora of benefits to human subjects
the ability to regenerate damaged DNA by
heightened excitement of cellular
duplication and producing a frightening
increase in the effectiveness of the
human immune system even upon testing
the liquid on animal subjects hostile
bacteria and viral agents were destroyed
immediately members of the 05 Council
are experts at cheating death and SCP
006 is just another Ace hidden up their
sleeve in the endless battle against the
reaper a secret so well guarded that
they willing to terminate even their
most loyal servants to keep it safe
after all if everyone knew about it
everyone would want it and the 05
Council are very invested in exclusivity
never normally one to rise above his
station Commander McGrath couldn't help
blurred out but if it was all Li private
Stewart is perfectly alive all smoking
mirrors you see and like everyone who
works a 006 mission he won't remember a
thing good work Commander McGrath 05 -2
now in perfect health replied now return
to your post after a visit to our boys
and amnestics there's still plenty to be
done and we can't afford to dilly d
after all you're not getting any younger
sometimes certain situations in life
have you wishing for a quick way out
waiting to have a meeting with your boss
heading into an important test or
getting ready to have an awkward
conversation with a romantic partner who
just texted that we need to talk all of
these can be pretty hard to deal with in
times like these it can be easy to want
to run away we feel a part of ourselves
saying that it would just be better to
just bail out as quickly as we can but
just because choosing to make an exit is
often the quickest way to avoid a
problem that doesn't always mean it's
the best solution especially when your
means of Escape Venture into the world
of the anomalous sometimes you have to
face things head on but if you are still
really in need of a quick way out then
SCP 120 might just be what you're
looking for but don't say we didn't warn
you now hear us out yes we know that
it's a children's paddling pool you
might have even owned one yourself back
in the day when the warm summer months
came rolling around your younger self
would have begged your poor parents to
spend several minutes in the sun's
glaring heat breathlessly inflating a
pool just like it then filling it with
water from the garden hose all so that
you could put on your water wings have a
splash around for an hour or two then go
inside to dry off the result leaving the
water in that paddling pool to go
stagnant as it got left outside in the
Summer sun filled with dirt leaves and
mosquito larvae while you decided that
air conditioning in Super Mario was a
better way to spend your time but SCP
120 as will likely come as no surprise
is no ordinary children's paddling pool
sure it might look like an ordinary
paddling pool at first pastel pink in
color only 2 and 1/2 m in diameter and
less than a meter tall it's even made
out of that same typical flimsy plastic
that needs to be inflated with air to
hold its shape you know the kind that
absorbed all the heat from the sunlight
while your younger self was out there
splashing around just waiting to burn
your skin at the slightest touch but the
first key difference between SCP 120 and
the pool you had while you were growing
up is wow this one is indestructible
despite being made from common Earth
Plastics SCP 120 cannot be damaged or
destroyed by any conventional means
though the material it is made from will
still Flex when pressure is applied and
is soft to the touch it also possesses
an anomalous tensile strength in other
words SCP 120 cannot be ripped stretched
or otherwise destroyed like an ordinary
paddling pool can and the SCP Foundation
would know they've destroyed their own
fair share of paddling pools in the
research Labs okay so SCP 120 is an
indestructible child's paddling pool
surely there has to be more to it than
that that otherwise why would it be such
an important object to the SCP
Foundation well you're right there's
much more to it than that after all they
don't call it the teleporting paddling
pool for nothing within the pool itself
is a glowing substance almost like a
liquid but somehow unlike any in
existence at least in this Dimension
what exactly do we mean by that well
this liquid doesn't behave in quite the
same way you would expect from say water
for example and its physical properties
don't align with the rules of our
universe let's say you fill your
ordinary paddling pool with water just
like you would have done on a hot summer
day as a kid now because of the
properties of the water you know you
could easily grab a drinking glass from
your kitchen cabinet and fill it up from
the pool no problem however the
substance within SCP 120 does not obey
these same rules you simply cannot grab
a glass or other container and scoop up
some of this glowing liquid see what we
mean the liquid is only really a liquid
in name and can't be manipulated in the
same way that an ordinary liquid can
however it does share the appearance of
being a liquid with its surface Rippling
and shimmering often as it moves so put
all that together and what is the
conclusion you get that this substance
definitely does not exist in our own
Dimension instead it is from somewhere
else entirely by far the biggest
difference between SCP 120 and any
ordinary pastel pink colored Walmart
paddling pool is the property that the
foundation is most interested in in fact
this paddling pool is part of the oh so
rare category of scps that actually have
a practical use thanks to this anomalous
property human beings along with the
clothes that they're wearing and any
items they may be carrying will be
teleported to one of 11 different
locations should they fall into the
paddling pool to reiterate they don't
call it the teleporting paddling pool
for nothing there are some small
limitations to SCP 120's teleport
rotation ability for one the weight of
the objects or loads being carried
through it by one person cannot exceed
the maximum threshold of just under 38
kilos or almost 84 lb there are also
only 11 destinations that SCP 120 can
send someone to and these can't be
pre-programmed or predetermined
beforehand any subject stepping into the
pool must be conscious carrying weight
under the specified amount be
biologically a human being and can only
use the teleporting paddle point pool
one person at a time meeting these
requirements means that the pool will
work as expected the only repercussion
of not meeting the affirm menion
criteria is simply that the pool will
not function any who have stepped into
the pool carrying too much weight for
example have merely reported that their
feet touch the surface beneath the
glowing liquid first encountered by the
SCP Foundation in September of
1992 SCP 120 was found in California
following reports of children going
missing in the area there they disc
discovered the teleporting paddling pool
and brought it back to site 19 for
testing it is currently unknown how many
children went missing or if they were
ever recovered regardless remember how
we talked about making a quick exit at
the start of this video well that's
because the foundation's biggest
interest in SCP 1220 was to use it as a
means of Rapid evacuation for their most
important group of people the OverWatch
command also known as the 05 Council
during a major emergency like a
containment breach the 5 would use the
paddling pool to escape to safety as you
may have gathered from how we've
described it SCP 120 has the inert
ability to instantly relocate a person
from one place to another according to
the theories of the SCP foundation's
researchers it likely does this by
allowing the subject to pass through one
or more Dimensions alternate to our own
we've also mentioned that one of the
limits of SCP 120 is that it can only
send someone to one of 11 different
places these are distinguished by the
liquid like substance contained in SCP
120 undergoing a change of color by
sending disposable members of d-class
personnel carrying radio beacons through
the foundation has been able to compile
a list of these destinations and they
are as follows the first of these is the
Pacific Ocean denoted by a blue glow of
SCP 120's liquid when traveling here
subjects are deposited about 2 m above
the surface of the Pacific since this
location was discovered during testing a
foundation vessel named the scps demer
has been stationed at these coordinates
to the public this ship is known instead
as the USS Nassau operating under the
cover story of being a simple
meteorological boat but why would the
foundation leave a boat here the current
position of this ship means that anyone
traveling to the Pacific through the
teleporting paddling pool will appear in
the vessel's cargo hold in a crisis
important Personnel could be sent to the
demer and the boat could even be used to
hold less dangerous SCP objects if they
could be sent through SCP p120 of course
teleporting oneself aboard a boat might
be a bit trickier say during a storm if
the demer is moved too far from its
current position there's a chance
someone might end up teleporting inside
one of the ship's walls the next
location is Greenland where SCP 1220
will send someone when its liquid glows
white arriving here one will find
themselves in a facility that the
foundation has established on site the
cover story for this one is that this
building is part of an expansion of the
oil industry what members of the public
are not privy to is the true function of
the facility the foundation set up this
site specifically to perform the same
function as their ship the demer the
facility even has an air strip and a
refueling station there meaning any who
use the paddling pool to teleport to
Greenland can further relocate
themselves aboard a foundation aircraft
if necessary if the liquid in SCP 120
ever changes to become a deep black in
color it will then lead to one of five
possible points that are all practically
identical the these destinations are
various Earth Moon lrange points in
Celestial mechanics a lrange point is
the area near two large bodies orbiting
in space to put it in simple terms in
this case these are points between the
Earth and the moon where the
gravitational forces of both balance
each other out this is what makes these
lrange points such a good location for
satellites as the equal forces make it
easier for a satellite to achieve the
right path of orbit so objects or people
sent through SCP 1220 when the water BL
La will end up at either lrange Point 1
2 3 4 or 5 these points are located all
the way around the earth and are
directly between the Earth and the moon
whenever the latter makes its orbit
around the former essentially jumping
through the teleporting paddling pool
when it has been dialed to one of these
locations is like taking a high dive
into the cold endless vacuum of space
ending up lost forever impossible to
retrieve the SCP Foundation plans to
potentially use these scp1 20
destinations to dispose of anomalous
objects during a crisis as a way to
prevent them from falling into the wrong
hands now we mentioned that SCP 120's
liquid will glow white when it's linked
to the destination in Greenland but the
same also occurs when it's dialed to the
snowcapped mountains of the Himalayas
this famous mountain range in Southern
and Eastern Asia is home to a number of
planet Earth's tallest Peaks most
notably Mount Everest the highest
mountain in the world resting at the
border between Nepal and China unlike
some of the other destinations the
foundation has made little change to
this one no boats or bases for anyone to
materialize into safety have been
designated to the area instead there's
just an 8 m hole where the bodies of
d-class test subjects have been disposed
of hidden from view by a canopy only in
extreme cases would the 05 Council ever
want to evacuate here should SCP 120
display a yellow glow then someone
traveling through it will arrive in the
Sahara Desert in Africa the s Hera is
being famous for being the largest hot
desert in the entire world only beaten
in size by the northern Arctic and
Antarctic deserts located here is a much
smaller Foundation installation an
outpost that would most likely be
ineffective for housing anomalous
objects but in and evacuation could
prove to be a useful hiding place for
important SCP documents or even for
members of the OverWatch command if SCP
1220 produces a brown glow in its liquid
it will transport a subject to the GOI
desert a region in northern China and
Southern Mongolia famous for its unique
ecosystem here much like the Sahara
location the foundation has established
an identical small Outpost however this
one comes with the threat of another
anomaly SCP
4024 this is a saltwater spring that is
gradually expanding across the GOI which
much like the teleporting paddling pool
has the ability to displace people and
objects to an unknown location finally
should scp1 ever emit a subdued grayc
colored glow traveling through it would
lead to an area in the sea of rains but
that's not a sea on Earth that's on the
moon and it's not so much a sea as it is
a vast plane luckily if you were to end
up here the foundation has already
thought ahead and set up a station on
the lunar surface and it's thought to be
one of their safest so at least if the
teleporting paddling pool sent you to
the Moon you would be able to survive
that's reassuring of course the real
problem is how do you get back home
that's a question for another day just
like we told you at the start of the
video sometimes it's better just to face
your problems headon because certain
escapes can lead to more complications
than you bargain for it is certainly not
unheard of for a young girl to wake up
in the middle of the night looking for a
glass of water it is somewhat more
exceptional when this late night water
Run results in many many deaths unless
of course you're dealing with a very
special young girl
SCP 053 also known as well the young
girl she possesses the innate ability to
inspire delusions paranoia and
eventually homicidal rage in anyone who
spends too long around her which as you
can probably imagine makes it hard to
live a normal life one night the young
girl woke up to something incredibly
strange the door of her cell typically
tightly sealed was wide open and a
strange flashing red light was shining
in through the hallway the sound of a
distant alarm is what had woken her up
what the young girl didn't know was that
the sight confining her had just
experienced a mass Containment Breach as
a result of a major electrical
malfunction some of the most terrifying
creatures imaginable were roaming the
halls in search of violence and Carnage
but when the young girl got up and
wandered out of her bedroom she only
wanted a glass of water to quench her
midnight thirst she wandered down a long
plain hallway washed intermittently in
read by the red flashing emergency
lights she robbed the sleep out of her
eyes and yawned all this strange
commotion maybe she's just having a bad
dream but what seems like a bad dream to
her is a Bonafide living nightmare for
everyone around her a few Halls over
security Personnel were being devoured
Alive by SCP 682 SCP 106 the old man had
just dragged a senior researcher into
his pocket Dimension to do unspeakable
things to him and a group of terrified
admin staff are being lured out by what
they think is a group of mobile task
force operatives but is actually a pack
of hungry SCP 939 imitating their voices
still the young girl persisted in her
quest for a refreshing drink even as
security personel began to Fan out
through the building hoping to get
control over this rapidly devolving
situation A group of five armed security
officers ran into the hallway and
attempted to intercept the young girl
but the high stress they were feeling
was only accelerated by the effects of
the young girls anomalous Powers they
started to feel bugs crawling all over
their skin they started to get the sense
that their fellow security officers
weren't even people but monsters wearing
human skin suits their paranoia soon
evolved into a blistering rage each of
the men pulled out their guns and began
firing at each other until only one was
left standing wounded but alive with all
the others dead the object of his rage
now became the young girl herself he
understood then that it was all her
doing that she made him do this she was
a monstrous little creature who took
pleasure in twisting the minds of human
beings into terrible forms in reality
the young girl had no such feelings her
powers were passive she had no control
over them she even suffered from some
kind of strange mental block that left
her completely unaware that her powers
were even taking effect she was in a
sense completely completely innocent as
the security officer pointed his gun at
the young girl as she began walking into
a nearby breakroom he experienced her
secondary anomalous effect anyone who
attempts to hurt her will immediately
die from either a heart attack or a
stroke the security officer suddenly
felt an intense pain sharp and brutal
exploding in his chest he collapsed dead
before he even hit the ground and the
young girl had no idea she couldn't if
she tried in the break room the Young
girl found exactly what she was looking
for a classic office water cooler
complete with a stack of plastic cups
perfect she carefully took one of the
cups and pulled down the lever on the
cooler watching her cup fill as the tank
above the cooler bubbled she took a sip
cool Refreshing Spring Water just what
the doctor ordered but the young girl
suddenly looked up shocked to see that
the tank above the water cooler was now
shaking violently as though it was going
to explode what was going on here had
she broken it she stepped back dropping
the rest of her cup of water to the
ground she felt frightened that's when a
crack formed in the plastic tank and the
water began slithering out not dripping
or pouring slithering as though it had
moved with mind and purpose and that's
because in this case it did the young
girl hadn't just drank any water she had
drunk half a cup of water from SCP 054
the water nyph a mysterious sentient
Woman made entirely from water much like
the young girl the water nymph is often
a misunderstood anomaly one that has
received far more harm from the cruel
treatment of the SCP Foundation than
she's ever given to another she's a
naturally curious and compassionate
creature whose trust has been abused so
when the contained breach alarm started
to sound much like the rest of the
foundation staff she had tried to hide
and find cover not wanting to fall into
the crosshairs of a far more dangerous
and hostile anomaly she had chosen was
in the water cooler in break room 3
which seemed like a genius idea until
the young girl turned up after years of
being experimented on by Foundation
researchers the water nymph wasn't just
about to tolerate more mistreatment
whatever this strange little creature
was who had just consumed some of her
body the water nymph would fight back
and make it regret ever thinking that it
could take advantage of her the young
girl who really had just made an
innocent mistake began to panic and run
as frightening slithering t tendrils of
pure water came slithering after her as
the unfortunate security guard
discovered earlier trying to attack the
young girl was typically a one-way
ticket to a heart attack or fatal
cerebral event but seeing as the water
nymph had neither a heart nor a brain
she was invulnerable and the young girl
was terrified she ran out of the room
past the bodies of the men who had
killed each other due to her influence
outside she wasn't even able to notice
them she kept running and the water of
the water nymph came slithering after
her the water nymph had never been the
vengeful type but after the abuse she'd
suffered she learned the value of
putting her liquid foot down she would
not tolerate mistreatment even from a
being this small the young girl kept
running Breathing heavily because of the
nature of her anomalous abilities nobody
could intervene and help her
occasionally she had run into groups of
foundation Personnel trying to fight
their way through the chaos only to be
anomalously affected and become part of
the chaos themselves they became violent
deranged monsters and started attacking
each other punching and biting as they
fell to the ground in a brawling pile
the young girl had to desperately climb
over them as the streak of furious
liquid followed her meanwhile across the
facility The Vicious Psychopathic old
man was hungry from war his mouth
stretched into a wide sadistic grin and
he continued walking further into the
base he would find new victims he would
feel their fear and drink in their dying
screams several mobile task forces were
dispatched from other nearby containment
facilities they'd likely reach the
embattled sight within the hour but how
many lives would be lost before then the
death count was already well into the
double digits after all this running the
young girl was getting tired it was rare
that she needed to truly avoid an escape
a threat like this and as such she
wasn't exactly prepared for such a
scenario she found her way into a broom
closet and locked herself inside hiding
among mops and brooms she tried to quiet
her breathing holding a tiny hand over
her mouth red flashes continued to
occasionally illuminate the corners of
the door she breathed in and out in and
out was something waiting outside the
young girl gasped as water started
bubbling underneath the door it started
looking around her feet then rising up
from the ground to the young girl it was
astonishing the water was forming the
shape of a woman standing right in front
of of her her lower lip trembled with
fear for a moment she was at a loss for
words then she gulped dry and began to
speak in a soft little voice I'm so
sorry I didn't mean to hurt you I
promise I was just thirsty the water
nymph tilted her head slightly confused
did this tiny child really mean this was
it an honest mistake after all the
terrible things that had been done to
her the water nymph had difficulty
trusting humans but as the young girl
started to cry for reasons she couldn't
quite understand the water nym felt the
urge to comfort her perhaps she wasn't
with the foundation perhaps this girl
was just another prisoner they were
allies not enemies while the water nymph
couldn't speak as a show of solidarity
she began to transform she got smaller
herself becoming a little girl made of
water almost mirroring SC SCP 053 she
raised a hand and waved the young girl
giggled seemingly put at ease it' been a
long time since she met a new friend
around here and it seemed like the water
nymph was ready to change that maybe
they could escape this place together
the young girl opened the door and the
two of them ran out together passing
through an adjacent hallway the young
girl ran while the water nymph slithered
formless along behind her they managed
to sneak around and avoid detection from
the many anomalies and Foundation guards
duking it out for Supremacy in the
chaotic Halls of the facility in a sense
it provided the perfect cover for the
unlikely Duo to escape this bizarre
situation
but they weren't out of the metaphorical
woods yet first they were cornered by a
trio of paranoid guards all wielding
handguns however the young girl's
nightmarish ambient ability came in
handy once more the three men lost their
minds and started killing each other
giving the young girl and the water
nymph more time to escape and keep
moving though they were about to
encounter the deadliest threat of all
the young girl took Point leading the
water nymph down the nearest hallway
when suddenly SCP 106 six the old man
emerged from the wall right in front of
her he had such anomalous malice in him
that the young girl's Powers was
effectively useless against him he
grinned and approached her his arms
extended ready to F her off to the
nightmare of his pocket Dimension the
young girl had never felt so afraid
until suddenly the water nymph slithered
in between them and she assumed her full
humanoid form once more forming a wall
between the young girl and the old man
this turned out to be the perfect way to
save the young girl's life SCP 106 has
historically found liquid barriers
incredibly confusing and it's been
widely considered to be one of the few
ways to effectively delay the old man's
Rampages seizing the moment the young
girl turned and ran away the water nymph
had just saved her life sadly for them
neither the water nymph nor the young
girl escaped that day the mobile task
force arrived and took control of the
facility again recontain the various
anomalies who had escaped but even if
they never never saw each other again
the water nymph and the young girl would
forever remember how they helped each
other on that incredibly strange day if
you've ever taken a vacation to one of
the many islands of Greece then you'll
know why the likes of CIT Lesbos and
Corfu are famous for their beautiful
beaches but there is one beach in
particular tucked away in a corner of an
unknown Island that you might think
twice about visiting why well the same
reasons that this place happens to be a
site of great interests for the SCP
Foundation also tend to drive tourists
away today we're talking about SCP
2217 the strange anomalous happenings
that have taken place there and how it
links to none other than one of the
foundation's most infamous groups of
interest at first glance SCP 2217 is an
ordinary uninteresting Beach just
another pretty picturesque view on a
Greek island it looks like the kind of
place that would be perfect for a r
romantic walk at Sunset but we wouldn't
recommend it although you wouldn't know
just from looking at it the sand that
this beach is composed of has some
pretty peculiar properties it contains
the ordinary non-anomalous things you'd
find in sand anywhere else in the world
normal levels of silicates and calcium
compounds but the beach also possesses a
high concentration of cationic metallic
particles these tiny almost microscopic
metal fragments somehow hold an
electrical charge to despite being
grounded so it's a beach with partially
metal sand nothing too unusual there
right wrong the metallic particles
within the sand seem to have a profound
effect on the natural environment around
SCP
2217 for one the metal content of the
beach influences the weather increasing
the number of lightning strikes that hit
the shore the metals draw the static
electricity in the atmosphere this along
with other weather conditions and
natural processes that take place at SCP
2277 also have a far more obvious
anomalous effect lightning rain even
fish washed up in decaying on the
shoreline have all caused various
artificial structures and devices to
rise from the beach which have all been
designated by the foundation as SCP
complicated automatons these machines
have no notable anomalous properties as
far as the SCP Foundation has found
apart from the way they came to be and
they are otherwise fully functional also
discovered at SCP 2217 was jewelry
seeming to be made of discarded waste
that washed up on the beach in the tide
resembling bears and other recurring
motifs of a certain religion these
articles of jewelry have been made using
everything from old light bulbs to holes
of ships and even fish and animal bones
most notably however was the appearance
of a city or rather a model of a city
that was created at the beach and was
then referred to as SCP
22171 there's a cliff located on SCP
2217 and if one is to swim through an
underwater entrance they will find
themselves inside a grotto they're
somehow carved by tital erosion of the
rock is a recreation of an ancient Greek
city although the geographic features of
the model seem to resemble an area near
Lake Bal in southern Siberia the city
Bears more of the same religious
iconography to the jewelry that can
often be found on the beach but which
religion the same one that considers SCP
2217 to be a site of holy importance the
Church of the broken God now some
important context to make note of for
any who are unaware the Church of the
broken God is a religious organization
that the SCP Foundation has had a number
of encounters with over the years
members of the church share in their
belief that biological flesh- based life
is inherently wrong an Abomination even
evil this religion worships
mechanization the process of making
something or someone more mechanical in
nature according to the beliefs of the
church there were two gods yabo and
mechain who created Humanity together
yabo was the god of Flesh and animal
instinct granting human bodies meanwhile
the god of machine and intellect mechain
blessed man with the power of free
thought as humankind developed its
civilizations by building machines
yalalo became enraged that they were
ignoring the instincts she had bestowed
upon them she endeavored to destroy the
creations of man in an attempt to revert
them to the animals she had intended
them to be as the church's Legend goes
mckain acted as Humanity's Savior and
tried desperately to stop yabo the god
of machine shattered himself
transforming his body into a number of
pieces to form a cage for his fellow God
fragments of mechain rained down on
planet Earth now the Church of the
broken God believes it is their duty to
recover these missing parts and put
their savior back together within the
religion of the Church of the broken God
there exists a splinter faction that
broke away from the main church this
group referred to as the broken church
are the ones that regard SCP 2217 so
highly considering it to be a holy sight
according to a piece of scripture from
their religion the broken Church
believes the beach to be Main's Workshop
the book of writs describes the legend
of a boy looking out at the ocean with
his family and seeing fire rain down on
the shore sent from God or mechain to
the church mechain apparently proclaimed
that the beach was his Workshop where he
made Many Wonders the lightning is my
hammer the Earth my Anvil the sand my
Ingot McCain explained to the boy so the
legend goes and invited the child into
his Workshop the broken God brought his
hammer down on the boy but instead of
killing him marked him as the first of
the religion the broken church now
follows in 2014 the SCP Foundation
recorded an earthquake taking place at
SCP
2217 with The Grotto containing the
model of the ancient Greek city at the
epicenter sending a otic probe Into The
Grotto to assess the damage only to find
a surprising change that had occurred
for the first time there were a number
of humanoid figures seen within SCP
22171 and worse still they were under
attack within the model City what
appeared to be a number of individuals
infected with SCP 610 were ransacking
buildings devouring and infecting the
other humanoid figures also known as the
flesh that hates as SCP 610 is a
contagious skin disease it is usually
transmitted by direct skin-to-skin
contact and anyone that is infected with
It suffers a horrific mutation that
transforms them into fleshy inhuman
monstrosities these infected creatures
will attack and infect anyone nearby
that isn't also carrying SCP 610
interestingly the disease was first
discovered to be localized to a small
area in Siberia not dissimilar to the
area that the SCP
22171 model resembled According to some
sources SCP 610 is the flesh described
by those following the religion of
sarcasm a cult that worships flesh and
disease sarcasm is a sect that directly
opposes and antagonizes the Machine
revering Church of the broken God 3
years after the earthquake members of
the broken Church staged an attack on
the beach hoping to reclaim SCP 2217 for
their religion at the time the SCP
Foundation had closed off the area to
the public under the cover story that
SCP 2217 was private property they had
been hoping to predict the lightning
strikes that caused the anomalous
devices to form on the beach instead the
foundation had to repel the broken
Church's attackers any way they could
however as the lightning began to strike
again members of foundation Personnel
that found themselves caught in it
seemed to change sides all stating that
God needs to be reassembled only a year
later in 2018 another group of broken
Church zealots stormed the beach and the
foundation Outpost located there this
time the church seemed to have gained
further reinforcements specifically
members of other groups of interest in
particular some belonging to the Church
of maxwellism and the cogwork Orthodox
Church both of which were also Splinter
groups of the Church of the broken God
the cogwork Orthodox Church arose during
the Industrial Revolution believing that
adding mechanical parts to their own
bodies offered greater understanding of
mechain and brought them closer to their
God maxwellism in a similar vein had
another interpretation of the church's
core beliefs favoring smaller more
advanced cybernetic implants the Church
of maxwellism sought to modify their
brains to become a collective
Consciousness and commune with mechain
despite a lot of pre-existing animosity
between the three core Splinter groups
of the church they were able to
successfully capture scp2 27 the three
factions sent a video message to the
foundation proclaiming the importance of
their mission oh disassemblers who call
themselves a foundation what are you a
foundation for if you are a foundation
for life then you will let us keep this
land for the flesh is coming and only we
can stop it we need to bring our God
back together immediately or else you
will all perish and now it is time if
you are a foundation for life you will
not let this happen you will let us
defeat the flesh several more messages
were sent to the foundation demanding
the release of various scps with
connection to the broken God you see
there could potentially be hundreds of
pieces needed to rebuild mechain so he
can lead the church to glory and defeat
yalah a number of these pieces happen to
be cataloged scps and the foundation is
either aware of or has in containment
these include SCP 882 or his broken
heart to the church SCP 271 his broken
gift SCP 8813 his Broken Eyes SCP 1139
his broken tongue SCP 635 his broken
mind and finally his broken blood which
refers to SCP 217 with the beach under
the control of the Church of the broken
God any foundation Personnel Left Alive
on SCP 2217 defected and joined the
church in order to retake the beach and
reestablish containment the foundation
was forced to do something that they
only do in the most dire of
circumstances ask for help together with
the Horizon initiative and Global occult
Coalition the SCP Foundation established
what it called the triumvirate a Joint
Task Force in 2019 another earthquake
was detected this time in Lake ball
Siberia where SCP 610 was contained not
long after infected individuals were
reported to be attacking Foundation
forces in the area causing heavy
casualties
but then an unlikely event took place
members of the Church of the broken God
appeared their bodies augmented with
Machinery these zealots that had fought
the foundation for control of SCP 2217
were now coming to its Aid to repel SCP
610 according to them God or rather
meccan had told them to come to assist
the foundation using a large scale
electrical discharge instances of the
SCP 610 contagion were eradicated but
this discharge charge seemed to have
originated from the same island where
SCP 2217 was found following this
incident Robert buero the leader of the
broken Church sent a video message to
the leaders of the triet including the
05 Council the director of the global Co
Coalition and the Horizon initiatives
tribunal in his message buero stated
it's not too late you know this is our
world as well we both want the flesh to
end and we can help you we can help each
other come to the Anvil we will talk and
we can save this world the Church of the
broken God its Splinter groups uniting
to take SCP 2217 for their religion were
now extending an olive branch to the
foundation and its allies all in the
name of protecting the world shortly
after the foundation Global cult
Coalition and Horizon initiative began
working collaboratively with the Church
of the broken God to prepare for an XK
class scenario retaking control of the
CP 2217 Beach for now the foundation
intends to revoke this current
Arrangement after the dangerous scenario
has been averted but perhaps McCain's
Workshop will provide vital in
reassembling the broken God and saving
Humanity should yal deach ever return to
exact her terrible Revenge violent chaos
unfolds across the shoreline huge fleshy
tendrils Slither out of the water
grabbing people who try to flee and drag
them into the depths as giant har poons
made of bone whiz across the beach
cutting down unfortunate sunbathers and
droves it is a terrifying Massacre but
you'd never in a million years be able
to guess its source on April 10th 2010
something strange began to happen in the
three Portlands now the anomalous
extradimensional city state that
overlaps with the locations of Portland
Oregon Portland Maine and the aisle of
Portland is no stranger to unusual
occurrences so it took the population a
little while to notice that something
was happening but for some unknown
reason sailboats and motorboats were
beginning to vanish from the city the
disappearances occurred overnight when
there was no one around to witness them
but slowly the citizens began to notice
that their friends and family members
were going out in their watercrafts and
never returning home by April 15th the
civilians were becoming noticeably
concerned fearing the worst on April
16th the worst fears were confirmed when
two local ghosts Anar Ahmed and Greg
Moore went for a nighttime stroll along
the harbor they heard a sudden commotion
and rushed to the scene of the
disturbance they arrived just in time to
see a living individual being dragged
into the watery depths by a large
veinlike tendril ammed asked Greg to
wait on land while he ventured out into
the water to look for the victim
unfortunately ammed never came back and
Greg took his story to the three
Portland Police Department after waiting
a few days for the local man and clam
populace to migrate the FBI unusual
incidence unit mounted a formal
investigation on the morning of April
17th all of the missing Vehicles
suddenly reappeared this left the uiu
and the people of the city with even
more questions where had all the boats
gone why were they suddenly back and
what had happened to the missing people
who had not been returned along with
them on April 19th uiu agents do into
the harbor to search for any unusual
activity and while they didn't spot
anything especially strange they did
discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual on April 21st
the threat that had been praying on the
citizens of three Portlands actually
made itself known at 11:19 a.m. 17 boats
moved away from the docks on their own
drifting up onto Shore though no one
could be seen captaining any of them as
the boats lined up they began to form a
wall blocked in access to the water no
one could get in or out civilians
watched in shock as the boats began to
warp and change before their eyes
growing thick masses of scales on their
surfaces sprouting Harpoon guns that
fired bony projectiles and slashing viny
tendrils at anyone within reach the
citizens began to panic running in every
direction in an attempt to escape the
Monstrous boats but they were too slow
to evade the attacks and the boats
snatched them off of the shore and
yanked them aboard using their harpoons
to impale those who managed to run
farther than the tendrils could stretch
as the army of fleshy boats closed in
around the shore a tugboat broke through
the surface of the water unlike the rest
of the boats it had a noticeable hole in
its Hull and was missing its wheelhouse
at an unnaturally quick Pace the tugboat
began to advance onto land using its
tendrils to drag itself along the shore
and into the more po populous part of
town it grabbed civilians at random
absorbing their blood into its metallic
surface as it went suddenly it spotted
Albert ISAT a noted member of the Church
of the broken God and began to focus its
attack on him but before the tugboat
monster could reach ISAT a city security
Golem interfered sadly though the Golem
put up a valiant fight the anomaly was
able to destroy it by Falling onto it
again and again until the gollum was no
longer able to get back up there are few
creatures that would survive having a
boat drop itself on top of them
repeatedly and sadly the security Golem
was not one of them with the goleem out
of the way the boat continued to drag
itself through the streets wildly
crashing through the side of a local
restaurant where its owner an entity
known as the GRL was in the middle of a
busy brunch service at the sight of the
invading watercraft the GRL set down his
piture of bottomless mimosas wiped his
hands on his apron and grabbed his his
trusty dual wield swords from underneath
the counter he kept them there in case
someone attempted to dine and dash but
he figured they would do just fine
against a blood drinking Tugboat while
the GRL kept the tugboat busy uiu forces
were able to break through the barricade
of boats for a brief period of time
allowing more security Golems to enter
the area as well as allowing more
citizens to escape unfortunately this
little victory was short-lived as
further unforeseen Horrors drudged the M
themselves up from the deep the
reanimated corpses of various species
native to the harbor began to crawl out
of the water surrounding the GRL and
allowing the tugboat to escape the fight
as it made its way back to the harbor
every boat it passed attempted to toss
bodies onto the tugboat covering it in
fresh blood slowly but surely the damage
to the tugboat began to repair itself
once the boat had regained its strength
it set its sights on a previously
untouched cargo ship and observing UI
officer determined that the boat was
somehow attempting to convert the cargo
ship to transform it into another one of
its fleshy allies but before the
transformation could take place a cargo
crate broke open spilling over 1,000
hardtack crackers suddenly the tugboat
stopped everything that it was doing it
took one tendril and began to count each
individual cracker that had Spilled Out
while the tugboat was distracted with
its task a citizen offered the uiu use
of their rare Metals Cannonball
collection in the fight to apprehend the
aggressive boat one particular
Cannonball made from electrum was able
to puncture the hole of one of the
infected ships rendering it motionless
they were elated to have found a weapon
that worked against these boats while
the tugboat continued to count the
remaining towns people gathered all of
the electrum they could find and began
to fight back against the boats one by
one the boats sank and all the while the
tugboat continued to count in the
meantime time uiu officers managed to
free the GRL from his zombie attackers
they presented him with an electrum
Cannonball which he proceeded to punch
finger holes into and wield like a
bowling ball then the GRL had a score to
settle no one whether human ghost or
tugboat was going to mess with his
brunch the guru barreled towards the
harbor grabbed hold of the still
distracted Tugboat and punched it hard
with his Cannonball fist if the tugboat
could breathe the punch would have
knocked the air out of its lungs the GRL
then threw the tugboat out of the water
and continued The Savage beating before
preparing to destroy the battered
vehicle once and for all he lifted it up
into the air jumped up to follow it and
hit it with so much force that the
tugboat caremed through the air
colliding with a portal that had
transported it to the aisle of Portland
luckily this portal could only be
unlocked via a high-speed impact from a
water-based vehicle speaking of luck an
SCP Foundation team was returning to the
aisle from a failed Mission just as the
anomalous boat appeared in their reality
the object was knocked unconscious by
the impact of its travel and the beating
from the GRL and in its incapacitated
state it was transported to a nearby
Foundation site there it was contained
in given the designation of SCP
6426 due to its anomalous traits
including the consumption of blood a
talent for hypnosis and a compulsive
counting habit it was also given the
nickname The Vampire boat SCP 6426 is a
ker class Sapient hostile entity that in
an inactive State Bears the appearance
of a harbor Tugboat in a constant state
of rust and degradation any blood or
organs containing blood that come into
contact with the boat will be absorbed
through the metal causing the
degradation to visibly improve as a
result the most effective blood appears
to come from humans sitations and a few
specific species of
salti the entity does not only use the
absor blood to improve its appearance
but is also capable of using it to
create organic additions to its body
including the vein-like tendrils spotted
in the three Portlands Cognito hazardous
eyes attached to bending eye stocks
Harpoon guns and cannons capable of
firing ammunition made from anomalous
species of barnacles these Barnacles are
capable of reanimating dead tissue on
contact and SCP 6426 frequently uses
them to create instances of SCP 6426 - c
masses of reanimated tissue that the
boat uses to Aid in its attacks or
self-defense SCP 6426 uses its tendrils
to grab prey and drag them towards
itself but the tendrils serve an
additional purpose as well each of the
tendrils has a mouth on the tip similar
in structure to that of the North
American medicinal leech when the
tendril has made contact with its prey
the mouth will then bite into the spinal
column of the creature causing its brain
function to cease as its canines grow
long and Hollow hard scales form on
their skin and their muscle mass and
bone density increase once they have
been transformed in this way organisms
taken by SCP 6426 are designated SCP
6426 these instances are used to the
entity's advantage helping it to extract
blood from victims at a distance as well
as providing an additional line of
defense and offense in the event that
SCP 6426 encounter another watercraft it
is able to use SCP 6426 daa to convert
the vehicle into an instance of SCP 6426
DB these converted boats are similar to
SCP 6426 and are able to function on
their own however they are unable to
produce their own ey stocks or cannons
unable to create SCP 6426 daa instances
and do not appear to be as intelligent
as their creator in the early days of
its containment the exact nature of the
anomaly's intelligence was the subject
of debate amongst the research staff
however on one specific occasion the
foundation was able to establish a line
of direct communication with SCP
6426 and conduct the first and so far
the only interview with the vampiric
tugboat the inciting incident occurred
when the arrival of the foundation's
latest hard tax shipment was delayed
leaving the boat with nothing to count
and nothing to keep it occupied freed
from the bounds of counting it managed
to escape and grab hold of several
Foundation staff members with its
tendrils after Chasing the boat through
the site guards were able to Corner it
prompting the boat to absorb the bodies
it had taken and used the organic
material to produce a siren that emitted
the sound of a human voice it is through
this siren that SCP 6426 responded to
interview questions using the voice of
one of its victims Junior researcher
sjad Williamson in spite of his protests
was selected to conduct the interview
his fellow staff members refused to take
no for an answer and as the newest hire
the unpleasant job fell on his shoulders
much to everyone's surprise the anomaly
began the conversation rather politely
saying I am so sorry I thought you were
those self-righteous lunatics from the
church I apologize profusely for any
trouble I may have caused and I want to
point out I fully support your mission
yes our first line of defense against
the undersea Menace I more than willing
to punch sharks Sal yes
right how rude of me yes Dr Williamson's
first question concerned SCP 6426
apparent intended victim back in three
Portlands Albert is at SCP 6426
responded Albert his first name is
really
Albert well what other relationship is
there to say besides the Hunter and the
hunted Admiral ISAT is a ruthless man no
known for terrorizing and slaughtering
people like me he was leading a search
party of those barbaric naop files
intending to gut me like a seal what do
you mean people like you Dr Williamson
inquired freethinkers of course people
who are unafraid to break from the mold
to carve their own path in life instead
of following the predetermined route set
by that ignorant check valve the church
is built upon a foundation of lies no
one's really a petty officer on the ship
we're all just cabin boys stumbling
around in the dark as we follow the
commands of an off-hand
C if you want real power real Freedom
all you have to do is listen for the
call of the Beast open the port hole and
he'll squeeze you right
through Dr Williamson feeling rather in
over his head attempted to convince one
of his colleagues to take over when he
refused however Dr Williamson continued
um could you explicate your activities
within the harbor and how you arrived
there well after I got the bans off my
trail I found a cave to hide in I was
forced to hide in yes forced to hide
deep in the cave which turned out to be
a tunnel surprisingly the tunnel led to
some Coastal Community where I took
Refuge licking my wounds in the safety
of the depths as those zealots stocked
the surface I spent my time preparing
Gathering the strength necessary to face
them once more until I was ambushed
assaulted within my Hideout by a bwian I
fought for my life as I was forced out
into the open and descended upon by a
manner of monsters and freaks of this
orchestrated by that scumbag eard I was
beaten within an inch of my life before
I'm not quite sure what happened after
after that I believe I was knocked
unconscious you'll have to Illuminate Me
on how I came to be in your custody at
this point the interview began to Veer
in an odd Direction the boat expressed
confusion about the nature of
Williamson's questions specifically how
little they related to the subject of
sharks and punching them it was at this
point that the site director sought
guidance from the multi U Department a
researcher there informed Williamson
about the confusion SCP 6426 had
mistaken the SCP found foundation for
another organization the shark punching
Center Dr Williamson resumed the
interview prepared to play along and
keep the boat comfortable unfortunately
Williamson was a terrible liar yes we
are the shark punching Center we will
determine if you are a suitable
candidate to carry out the mission to
search punch and
contain I mean cations this verbal
misstep caused SCP 6426 to become
suspicious after a moment it pieced
together the truth and began to throw
itself against the wall in a desperate
attempt to escape it was apprehended by
security guards who impaled it with a
naval RAM and returned the watercraft to
its containment cell the exact reason
for its apparent fear and hatred of the
foundation is currently unknown and the
boat has made no attempt to speak since
currently SCP 6426 is kept in a 39 m x
39 m x 50 m containment chamber beneath
the chamber there is an artificial lava
tube the tugboat has a naval Ram through
its Hall and engine holding it in place
this Ram is checked daily for signs of
degradation as it is the primary force
keeping the anomaly IM mobile if the ram
is ever removed or damaged somehow a
failsafe system will activate releasing
100 hard attack crackers and two pieces
of electrum into the containment chamber
this is intended to keep the tugboat
occupied until the naval Rod can be
replaced if for some reason the naval
Rod fails and the boat runs out of hard
attack to count well there will be
nowhere on water or land that we can
hide the ocean is a terrifying Place
we've all heard the statistics more than
80% of the ocean remains unexplored
that's most of the water covering the
globe completely unmapped and unobserved
by science it's a scary thought to dwell
on realizing that there's more water
than land on Earth and the sheer expanse
of that water is so large that we've
been unable to fully explore all of it
just think there there are places in the
ocean that have never been seen by a
human who knows what's down there if
there was ever a personification of fear
of the unknown the ocean could
definitely be it ancient shipwrecks sunk
to the ocean floor unknown sea creatures
hiding away from humanity and the
general isolation of the suffocating
dark blue the ocean swallows its victims
with all of these images that come to
mind when thinking about the vast and
mysterious depths of the sea and no one
is more familiar with nautical Mysteries
than the SCP Foundation today we'll be
taking a look at SCP 5007 the bass
straight a wave of oceanic anomalies fit
to make any seasoned sailor shiver in
fear the bass straight is an area of
ocean dividing Tasmania and the
Australian Mainland it's also the
location of an unusually high amount of
disappearances Sailors disappearing from
their ships fishermen leaving in the
night and never coming back even
civilians disappearing from the shores
that that connect to the straight the
foundation was aware of these
disappearances since 1858 but were only
able to craft theories about what was
causing them was it an anomalous group
of Interest hostile aerial entities
patrolling the skies above the straight
phenomenon associated with unidentified
flying objects what about Subterranean
anomalies weather patterns or time
dilation for nearly a century the
foundation was unable to determine the
cause of the high number of
disappearances in the bass straight and
then the the phenomenon suddenly
revealed itself in 1980 on a beach
connected to the straight agent Taber an
operative of the SCP Foundation was
vacationing with his wife Mary and his
three young children the Taber family
was simply enjoying their day when they
saw what looked like balloons in the sky
they were approaching quickly and
naturally the family moved closer what
happened next was a whirlwind and those
balloons the family were so interested
in Lifted them up from the ground and
carry them away agent Taber tried to
fight back but there was nothing he
could do except report to the foundation
what had occurred and the organization
responded in full force the foundation's
research discovered that reports of UFOs
and lights in the sky had coincided with
many disappearances in the straight and
that this was a pattern the search for
the four lost Taber family members had
become a large- scale investigation into
unexplained disappearances along the
bass straight and within 3 weeks it was
determined determined that these
patterns were consistent across the
entirety of the Strait's coastal regions
some witnesses were interviewed but the
vast majority of these abduction cases
had no Witnesses whatsoever of the
minimal reports filed the foundation was
told that there were lights in the sky
and that appearance of unidentified
flying objects described as having the
appearances of balloons one such witness
interviewed was a man by the name of
Alan Stewart a witness who was present
during The Disappearance of former
Australian prime minister Harold Holt
whose disappearance the foundation
believed may have had a connection to
the bast Strait anomalies during the
interview Stuart claimed that Holt and
his family while voyaging on their yacht
decided to leave the boat and go for a
swim Holt turned to Stuart and asked him
if he could see the balloons around the
cliff Stuart had no idea what Holt was
talking about but Hol was insistent on
seeing them he swam deep out into the
ocean saying that they weren't normal
balloons and that there was someone
inside of them steuart and H's family
called out for him to come to shore but
he wouldn't listen steuart tried to
rationalize what he saw next maybe it
was the current sweeping Holt away but
he couldn't lie to the foundation
interviewer Stuart saw Holt go further
and further out into the water and
suddenly the Prime Minister turned
around he began swimming in the opposite
direction and he was screaming suddenly
Holt was lifted from the sea and pulled
into the air by something emerging from
the clouds the foundation thanked
steuart for the interview and continued
their investigation 2 years later in
1982 Emergency Services received a large
number of calls pertaining to UFO
sightings off the coast of Norman Bay
Victoria the foundation was quick to
respond alerting task forces and local
sites to prepare for an investigation
upon arriving to the scene they
confirmed the existence of multiple
entities that would later be documented
as SCP 57 they evacuated civilians from
the area and successfully managed to
capture the creature which was later
transported to site 40 for containment
it was a sight to Behold The Entity now
designated SCP 57- S1 was a cluster of
human bodies fused between a grouping of
black tentacles of varying length each
tentacle was fused to the skin it
touched directly the stomachs of the
corpses were grossly swollen and
distorted to massive sizes to hold large
quantities of gases inside the Bucy of
which The Entity used to achieve a
passive flight across the entity's
surface were clusters of eyes and
bioluminescent glowing organs many of
the humanoid components of the corpses
appeared to have been removed and
misplaced across various parts of the
entity's body what's more is that the
foundation discovered that human
portions of SCP 5007 appeared somewhat
cognizant and aware of their situation
their vocalizations were incoherent and
barely understandable consisting of
gasping and whimpering but the corpses
were observed to implore other
individuals to approach them when
encountered SCP 57s behavior during
abduction scenarios was documented
during the initial containment event and
due to the foundation's painstaking
research a pattern was established
between all SCP 5007 encounters first
the victim would be alone or otherwise
vulnerable in a coastal location SCP
5007 haven't shown a preference for
weather be they clear or hostile Skies
but they have localized all of their
activity to the bass straight in small
coastal towns beaches or boats SCP 5007
will then move towards the shore
stalking the victim before lowering its
tentacles and appendages to grab the
individual snatching them into the sky
an SCP 57 instance can even abduct
multiple people at once one event
observed had eight men from the decks of
a commercial fishing boat taken into the
sky in under 15 seconds once captured
SCP 57 instances will Dart across the
water at high speed and take their
victims to an unknown location
discovering where SCP 5007 took their
victims became a top priority for the
foundation after extensive witness
interviews and compiling a database of
likely victims they determined that
there must be at least 16 instances of
SCP 57 unaccounted for personnel kept a
close watch on the coastlines and Waters
of the bass straight and equipped
various Marine task forces with research
vessels capable of tracking any instance
is if they encountered them in 1985 the
foundation's research efforts paid off
and several survey teams operating in
the area reported a sighting of an
extremely large SCP 5007 instance
heading towards a coastal town a mobile
taskforce was sent to track the entity
the team observed The Entity from afar
as it stocked a private fishing boat
even from the distance Foundation
Personnel recognized the likenesses of
several missing persons as faces of the
corpses of SCP 5 2007 the task force
Captain had to remind his team to keep
it together claiming that they were not
people but just parts of the specimen
but everyone secretly knew the truth the
fishing vessel was a private one
occupied by a small family The Entity
slowly approached and quickly pulled a
woman into the air the family panicked
and quickly tried to reach cover for
safety running into the Ship's Cabin The
Entity ran its tentacles along the boat
until it pulled the door open snatching
another two victims the task force was
unable to help them as their mission was
to track the instance to its origin
point it was a horror to watch the task
force implanted a tracking Beacon onto
the entity and quietly followed it out
to sea over the next 4 hours they then
discovered a large gray Reef with
several shipwrecks dotted across it 13
SCP 57 instances floated over the area
some holding on to the land Reef with
their tentacles The Entity dropped the
abduct from the fishing boat who were
coerced by the entities into diving into
a massive pool of water located in the
center of the reef one by one each
abductee was pulled below the surface by
something lurking in the pool all while
the SCP 57 instances watched disgusted
the task force reported what they
observed to the main site and the reef
would be designated as SCP
57- the foundation's analysis of the
reef led to the discovery that The Rock
covering it seeped iron oxide from an
unknown source and the Rocks achieved
growth at an anomalously fast rate often
as little as 40 minutes all of the wreck
ships and aircraft that washed across
the shore of the reef were covered with
a dark stone The Reef was teaming with
anomalous marine life including SCP 57 a
red algae that fed upon the freshly
grown Rock Marine worms capable of
levitation spiders that lived in silk
Retreats underneath the waterline small
fish and giant organisms resembling
large clumps of kelp which the
foundation had previously documented as
SCP 4159 in a separate investigation SCP
57 often rested their tentacles on the
outcroppings of the wreath while
inactive but what caught the
foundation's attention the most was the
giant pit located in the reef center
unmanned exploration drones found that
it had a depth of at least 4,000 M and
water samples taken from the pit
revealed large quantities of human DNA
prehistoric bacteria and unknown
compound that possess significant
life-preserving qualities when a being
was submerged in the compound they were
able to survive heavy injuries even when
fully surrounded by the liquid and
unable to breathe the foundation's
exploration of one of these shipwrecks
LED them to a journal most of it was
illegible due to water damage but one
passage survived located in the back of
the book it detailed the experience of
an unknown crew member of the ship
caught in the storm it reads Mosby spied
land ahead and the boys said that their
giant balloons hanging over the island
we are all a feared but there is not we
can do but Beach ourselves and help for
rescue should I be killed in the crash I
want my mates to give this journal to my
Mary might know I spent my last thinking
only of her the interior of the ship
contained human remains inside but there
were less skeletons than the foundation
would expect for a ship of its size the
location of the rest of the bodies was
unknown another event related to SCP
5007 the foundation documented involved
Frederick valentic a pilot engaged in a
training flight over the bass straet in
1978 Valenti's disappearance was marked
by his latest communication with air
traffic control when he mistook an SCP
5007 instance for an unidentified
aircraft it seems like it's stationary
but I'm doing right now is orbiting and
the thing is just orbiting on top of me
also it's got a green light and sort of
metallic like it's all shiny on the
outside shortly after this Valenti's
transmission was interrupted by what was
described as metallic scraping sounds
believed to be the SCP 5007 instance
attacking the aircraft and jamming its
propellers with its mass after crashing
into the reef it was believed that
valentic and his aircraft were pulled
beneath the surface of the pit just as
the abductees had been prior the
foundation decided to construct a
provisional secure research facility on
the reef they named it site 4-r and
documented all returns and departures of
SCP 5007 they also set up a series of
containment procedures that resulted in
SCP 5007 returning with its victims 83%
less often than before the site's
construction but this was short-lived in
2008 the site logged over 36 instances
returning to the reef with only two not
having any fresh abductees the instances
Origins were unknown and it was as if
they appeared out of thin air no other
monitoring post had documented their
appearance or even spotted them before
they arrived at The Reef it was years
later in 2017 that the foundation
eventually was able to successfully
explore what was deep inside the pit at
the center of the reef they already knew
that there was a large entity lurking
beneath as evidence by what happened to
the victims of SCP 5007 that were later
deposited inside the pool all previous
attempts to explore the pool were met
with failure as the water pressure of
the Pit's depths caused all craft to
collapse due to Hull damage this time
however they managed to construct a
high-tech submarine labeled the scps
Nautilus which was capable of diving a
maximum of
13,500 M underwater they decided that a
d-class Personnel would be trained to
man The submersible and carry out the
exploration the mission was simple the
Nautilus was to dive to the bottom of
the pit and to describe the depth
readings cameras and microphones were
equipped to the vessel due to the depth
remote viewing of the footage was
impossible instead the foundation had to
physically recollect the vessel in order
to view the footage upon recovery some
of the footage suffered data corruption
but what was there shook those who
viewed it to their core the footage
showed the DCL class's experience going
deeper inside the pit at first it seemed
ordinary the trench had a number of
Rocky outcroppings dotted with black
yellow Vines growing along the walls
also present were various marine life
forms such as the spiders or the fish
going deeper the sub observed an SCP 57
instance clinging to an outcropping
several tendrils emerging from the Pit's
depths were wrapped around the instance
and holding on to the entity as if it
were feeding from it another 16 SCP 57
instances were seen resting along the
walls each clinging to the outcropping
as the sub went deeper the d-class
remarked that there were dozens of plane
and shipwrecks but also well over 100
SCP 57 entities most of them were held
there by the black tendrils the d-class
as the sub went even deeper began
noticing hum human remains no short
amount of them either deep into the pit
there was a large mass of human remains
covering the entirety of the pit bodies
crushed and drained of blood but still
possessing intact eyes each individual
was still alive kept preserved by the
life- sustaining compounds found within
the water the body stared at the sub and
moved attempting to grab onto the
vehicle the d-class swore they were
trying to say something mouthing words
to the camera of the sub as the sub
passed through the mass of bodies it
emerged into a completely dark black
clearing at the bottom of the pit for a
second the declass thought he was safe
but then a large black tentacle rapidly
emerged from below and grabbed onto the
Nautilus dragging it even further Into
the Depths the declass screamed and
panicked but there was nothing he could
do the tentacle possessed a large
cluster of eyes mouths and human heads
seemingly grafted onto its mass and then
there was another tentacle and then
another the Nautilus was pulled to the
bottom of the pool the d-class screams
were still heard even as the picture cut
out sometimes graphic body altering
images of the tentacle features were
visible on the screen but most of the
footage was indecipherable after minutes
of distorted corrupted footage the
Nautilus was seen again rapidly
ascending to the surface somehow it had
managed to escape the entity at the
bottom of the pit upon recovery of The
Craft it was found that the Nautilus was
covered in a thick organic coating
similar to a black slime mold but with
dozens of eyes growing from it the
d-class inside showed severe
psychological damage and attempted to
harm Foundation Personnel they were
terminated shortly after due to being a
danger to those around them following
review of the footage the Nautilus was
to be dismantled and incinerated along
with the remains of the d-class a
reinforced containment seal was fitted
over the pit with the intention of
keeping whatever was down there isolated
from the surface but this was shortlived
after the containment seal was fitted
site 40 underwent a massive
Communications blackout every device on
site received an email containing a
single image of a large eye taken from a
security camera the text beneath it
simply read found you some Personnel who
viewed the email underwent anomalous
changes growing new physical features
such as eyes and other various growths
across their body the entirety of site
40- went offline and the foundation
could not establish contact in an
emergency effort to do so mobile task
force gamma- 6 deep feeders was sent to
investigate the task Force's assault on
site 40 Bashar was a daring effort as
the majority of the site was completely
overtaken by tentacles growths and
anomalous alterations while numerous
altered Personnel were lost due to the
mission it was ultimately a success some
altered Personnel were able to be saved
through extensive surgery to remove
their anomalous growths and after
everything was said and done the site
was repaired and reconstructed did
without incident following the sight's
repair there has been little activity
from The Entity within the pit but the
foundation continued to keep an eye on
the creature and the ecosystem of the
anomalous marine life that live on the
bass straight never knowing what their
next move might be and always keeping in
mind the risk that comes with dealing
with these poorly understood entities
Jack was swimming deep under water
wondering why he had such a pounding
headache when suddenly he had a
terrifying realization he had no idea
where he was or what he was doing there
was a nagging feeling that he must have
a specific reason to be here you don't
just end up deep in the ocean with a
diving suit on by chance yet he had no
idea what he was supposed to be doing he
wasn't sure he cared either he was more
worried about the throbbing pain in his
head and the vision of two eyes staring
at him out of the dark that he couldn't
get out of his mind his heart began to
race as he wondered what to do and how
to get help he was in the middle of the
ocean and appeared to be all alone he
couldn't see anything in the Dark Water
except for this weird gray substance in
front of him maybe he was going to die
here alone without knowing if anyone
could even hear him he began to speak
aloud about how he was consumed by
sickness and that Darkness was all
around him this is the story of one of
the most powerful and dangerous
anomalies yet discovered SCP 3000 before
Jack's descent into despair the SCP
Foundation had mandated an exploratory
Expedition off the coast of Bangladesh
after receiving a few strange reports
from locals and fishermen the foundation
suspected an SC P was lurking in the
water and positioned a few Personnel to
investigate the crew expected danger or
maybe even death but what they got
instead was Far stranger and more
ominous all of the men had been verified
to be in sound mental States when the
mission set out but a few of them
reported feeling strange and uneasy as
the submarine descended into the ocean
before long a veteran agent named Dr
Williams began to panic in a way that
was completely out of character he
started sweating profusely shaking and
wouldn't listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer it
might seem like a relatively normal
reaction for anyone descending into the
depths of the ocean to meet with a
monster that they don't know anything
about but Dr Williams was a seasoned
professional who had been on hundreds of
such missions before there was no
logical reason for him to act like this
although the reaction of Dr Williams was
the most extreme he wasn't the only one
who started to feel strange multiple
agents developed a creeping feeling of
unease that swept over them one of the
calmer men tried to reason with Dr
Williams asking him what was wrong and
if he could explain exactly how he was
feeling that's when things got even
stranger Not only was the doctor
extremely anxious but he now seemed
incapable of giving a real response to
any questions thrown at him he could
only mutter that he was missing
something but he wasn't sure what
knowing that many scps can bend reality
and the human mind many of the Personnel
began to have second thoughts about the
mission and even asked for permission to
call off the mission but they were
mandated to continue so they went on as
the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean things only got worse even the
previously calm crew members became
spooked and antsy while the ones who
were already anxious were now sweating
and jittering as for Dr Williams he was
now pacing back and forth around the
submarine saying things nobody could
understand every time he looked at his
colleagues and his close friends he
seemed to stare straight through them
and would call them by the wrong names
it was as if his mind had moved to a
different dimension whenever someone
asked him to perform his normal duties
he looked more confused than ever still
the team went deeper Dr Williams began
to whimper and say the word no
repeatedly growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others
were forced to sedate him just then
something came into view it was what
would come to be known as SCP 3000 the
thing was huge so huge that its whole
body couldn't be seen out of the
submarine window it was a horrible eel
looking creature with a head as big as a
town and haunting eyes that Lit Up The
Black Ocean around it but perhaps the
strangest part was this giant eel seemed
to be producing a weird gray liquid even
the sedative wasn't enough to keep Dr
Williams calm anymore there was a
strange blank look in his eyes as if the
light and life had left him and he just
began screaming no repeatedly again and
wouldn't respond to any attempts to calm
him down not that anyone else was very
capable of calming him down at this
point even the crew members that had
been holding up well were starting to
act strangely and nobody could get the
image of these ominous eyes out of their
heads then things went from bad to worse
Williams began screaming and shouting
madly as if he was being tortured by an
unseen Force the men tried to restrain
him but it was no use he began smashing
his head against the submarine window
until it cracked putting the whole
mission in everyone's life at risk he
felt to the ground injured chanting that
there was nothing whatever that meant it
was an emergency scenario they began
applying first aid to Williams as the
submarine ascended to the surface as
quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window
to explode by the time they reached the
surface Williams was dead but there was
something even more chilling than the
circumstances of his death every single
man who had been in that submarine
experienced the same thing on the days
that came afterward the image of the
eel-like creatures eyes seemed burned in
their minds permanently it would haunt
their waking hours for the rest of their
lives and sleep was no Escape either as
they would appear in both their dreams
and nightmares alike forever a second
mission had to be sent to gather more
information about the strange Beast
there were many theories and question
marks surrounding SCP 3000 how big was
it really was it sentient what was the
liquid for none of the men who had been
on the previous Mission were willing to
return to the waters but a new group of
Brave recruits volunteered they were
about to find out what so many in
history have learned the hard way that
bravery and foolishness are often
mistaken for the same thing this time
the mission would not be in a submarine
but in dive suits in order to observe
the anomaly in even closer detail and to
eliminate the chance of one team member
M self- sabotaging the submarine killing
them all they were transported to the
location by boat and the three men
splashed into the ocean they descended
and at first everything was going well
in case anything went wrong the three of
them were tethered together for extra
security but the deeper into the ocean
they swam and the closer they got to SCP
3000's location they got the stranger
things became just like on the last
mission first there were a few minor
cases of confusion one of the team Jack
thought it was his responsibility to
lead the navigation but another also
thought it was his job in fact
navigation was actually the job of a
third team member Amir but he seemed to
have forgotten everyone was getting
confused the team listening in on the
conversations at the foundation
headquarters grew increasingly concerned
about what they could hear was everyone
losing their minds hopefully nobody was
about to pull another Dr Williams on
them still the project leads couldn't
afford to tell the men to come back to
the surface the foundation badly needed
any information they could get on this
SCP whatever the cost so they told the
men to press on things only got worse
Roberto was asking to speak to a
colleague who passed away 2 years ago
while the others began to mutter
indistinguishable phrases about eyes and
darkness not too dissimilar to the
ramblings of Dr Williams it increasingly
began to look like a suicide mission
then there was silence what was going on
each of the men had completely lost it
to the point that they cut the tether
that was holding them together all alone
Jack couldn't remember where he was or
why he was here he desperately looked
around to try and Eng his surroundings
but he could only see Darkness all he
could think about was a pair of large
eyes and an overwhelming fear of Despair
and anxiety and this weird gray fluid
that was now floating in front of him
the foundation listened as Jack started
reciting a creepy speech about being on
the edge of nothing inches from Oblivion
with a sickness in his mind and nothing
but a pair of eyes in front of him they
listened in horror as they heard
movement through the radio it sounded
like a huge creature was swimming toward
the men it had to be SCP 3000 but all
three men were too confused to do
anything about the situation or to even
see what was in front of them claiming
they couldn't see anything in the
darkness there was silence for half a
minute with the team listening in
fearing the worst then they heard some
more unintelligible mutterings the men
must be alive but what on Earth was
going on then the gibberish started
again two of the men were screaming that
Jack had just been swallowed whole and
that they were being sucked in too why
couldn't they just swim away it was
chaos but then a few moments later
Roberto spoke into the radio saying he
was floating alone in the middle of the
ocean and had now moved away from the
eyes of SCP 3000 he finally seemed
capable of forming coherent thoughts and
speech after what had just happened
Roberto now had a theory he thought that
somehow it was impossible to think
straight around SCP 3000 when he'd been
close enough to see the eyes Roberto had
felt a throbbing pain in his brain and
been unable to think about anything
perhaps it was something to do with that
mysterious gray liquid even more slime
was coming out of SCP 3000 now and
Roberto was determined to get a sample
this despite the warnings from HQ in one
final burst of motivation he swam close
enough to take some of the gray liquid
and put it in a special sample
collection unit that was designed to
float to the surface for collection
later he had acquired some very
important data but he seemed to have
lost all hope of preserving his life
Roberto started telling the team over
the radio that he was dying and that his
heart rate was too high but cautioned
that it would be too dangerous for
anyone to try and rescue him the
Personnel continued to try and
communicate with Roberto to figure out
what was going on but his words had
stopped making any sense until finally
he went quiet minutes turned into hours
hours into days and still there was no
sign of Roberto or the rest of the
divers after 3 days His Radio which had
only been sending a steady stream of
Static finally stopped working
altogether and he was presumed dead
however the sample Roberto had collected
had survived and made it to the hands of
the foundation researchers it turned out
to be a viscous substance now known as
y99 a chemical compound and extremely
strong anesthesia y 99 causes head head
pain paranoia fear Panic memory loss and
confusion explaining what happened to Dr
Williams in the diving Trio the
collection of Y 909 might have resulted
in two disastrous missions but there's a
silver lining as the substance ended up
becoming an invaluable tool for the SCP
Foundation its ability to make people
forget what had just happened to them
can be used to eliminate knowledge of
threatening scps among the public it
also helps the foundation staff cope
with the traumatic experiences they
encounter on their missions although
other amnestics can be used for the same
purpose none are as powerful as the one
produced by SCP 3000 before its
Discovery the amnestics used would break
down too quickly not fare well in
storage or cause undesirable side
effects the only problem is the method
of sourcing the only way to obtain y99
is somewhat ethically questionable for
most people SCP 3000 produces y 99 after
eating so the best way to stock up on it
is by feeding the creature sedated
d-class Personnel from the foundation
are sent on Mission supposedly to
observe the anomaly of close unaware
that this mission is one way only other
divers are then sent later to collect
the fluid from a safe distance and store
it of course it's all for the greater
good of humanity now the foundation
protects SCP 3000 as best as it can
guard something hundreds of kilometers
long the area is carefully patrolled and
members of the public are not allowed to
enter the part of the bay where it
resides anybody who accidentally comes
into contact is contained eventually
another pair of foundation doctors went
down in a submarine to try and learn
more about SCP 3,000 one became so
affected by y 99 that he began
hallucinating he started talking about
anant shesha the king of serpents and
Hinduism anesa is believed to be all
that will be left after the end of the
world because it exists throughout all
of time simultaneously the doctor said
he believed that this was in fact an
anesa that SCP 3000 simply shows us that
eventually everyone dies and Fades into
the darkness of Oblivion right before he
exited the submarine and swam right into
his mouth luckily for now SCP P 3000
seems to be in a sort of hibernation
state it rarely moves and it doesn't
hunt although it will eat when fed but
no one knows when or if it'll wake or
what it's capable of if it does will it
destroy the world or simply drive us all
insane hello SCP Foundation Personnel
welcome to Cognito hazards and you
episode redacted this video series is
intended to teach you about the protocol
surrounding the various Cognito
hazardous anomalies currently within
Foundation containment when you know
better you do better and both you and
the secrets of our great organization
can stay safe and as anyone familiar
with a good Cognito Hazard can tell you
knowing really can make a difference
today's episode is about the unique and
dangerous SCP
2316 before we begin repeat after me and
be sure to speak clearly into the
microphone in front of you I do not
recognize the Bodies In The Water a
little louder please thank you you in
order to be educated about the following
SCP you must pass a vocal examination
with a cognitive resistance value of no
less than
14.5 through this video presentation you
will need to repeat the phrase to ensure
your score does not drop below the
approved threshold in the event that you
fail the test stay calm and remain where
you are until medical staff can retrieve
you remember safety is a top priority
when observing Cognito hazards the safe
way is is the only way you're a cog in a
very important machine and we wouldn't
want to have to terminate you now would
we one more time please I do not
recognize the Bodies In The Water very
good remember that you do not recognize
them no matter what you might think you
see your thoughts can be very unreliable
when you're around SCP
2316 according to our files on the
matter SCP 2316 refers to an anomal less
phenomenon identified in a Small Town
Lake it appears as a collection of human
bodies floating in a group on the
surface of the water the exact number of
corpses is unknown but it has been
estimated to be anywhere between 45 and
200 though the bodies belong to
individuals many researchers theorize
that the bodies in the water which you
do not recognize and you have never
recognized share a collective
Consciousness they function it would
seem with a hive mind of sorts the
bodies do not act on their own but as
one now where does the Cognito Hazard
come into play it would seen that anyone
who looks at the bodies in the water or
learns too much about SCP 2316 as a
whole begins to believe the corpses
floating in the lake are people they
recognize perhaps they remember their
faces from childhood or High School
whatever the case may be they become
convinced that the bodies in the water
are familiar and that they must approach
them
no matter how familiar they might seem
however you do not recognize the Bodies
In The Water if a person attempts to
enter the lake reaching out to whatever
instances of SCP 2316 they think they
recognize more bodies will begin to
appear the more bodies appear the more
familiar faces seem to manifest and the
deeper the person will venture into the
lake eventually the person is lost
within the Sea of bodies likely drowning
beneath the surface or simply becoming
one with the hive mind until they too
are one of the corpses there none of the
individuals who wandered into the lake
in search of an old friend or classmate
have ever been recovered there have been
no attempts to search the lake for their
bodies as it is unknown what effect SCP
2316 would have on the team assigned to
such a task though we can guess that the
outcome would likely be extremely
negative for all involved those who do
Venture into the lake simply disappear
never to be seen again if you look too
long at the bodies in the lake perhaps
their faces would surface alongside the
rest but it's best not to think about
that after all we do not recognize the
Bodies In The Water Foundation Personnel
are not allowed to approach SCP 2316
under any circumstances the lake is only
permitted to be observed via dummy
probes outfitted with video and audio
recording equipment no one is permitted
to observe any footage or audio file
collected unless they pass through a
screening for resilience to Cognito
hazardous anomalies the lake that holds
SCP 2316 has been fenced off and is
patrolled by guards with no prior
knowledge of or exposure to SCP
2316 anyone who attempts to approach the
lake and break through the boundaries of
its quarantine will be seized and taken
to site 33 for examination anyone who
comes within 50 m of the lake is
considered lost and presumed dead repeat
after me slowly and clearly into the
microphone I do not recognize the Bodies
In The Water good I almost believe you
let's continue only one Foundation
officer that entered the lake containing
SCP 2316 was ever stopped before they
could be lost their name has been
stricken from any official records and
you do not need to know it their
identity does not matter what matters is
the interview they gave following the
incident conduct by Dr Harrison in his
office Dr Harrison asked the anonymous
officer if they felt compelled to enter
the Water by an invisible force as if
pulled in they rejected this concept
entirely insisting that they entered the
water of their own free will they wanted
to see the bodies who appeared to them
as their friends they wanted to hear
what the bodies were saying upon
entering the water they saw the faces of
their friends other faces were
unfamiliar but became more familiar the
longer the officer stared at their
features these were faces they had known
their entire life but something about
them was just a little bit wrong it was
like the face of someone in a dream
where you can tell they are someone you
know and you can even identify who it is
supposed to be but something about them
does not quite look right your mind
could not perfectly put their face
together from memory even though the
feeling of familiarity Remains the faces
in the water peering up through the
darkness below were like those dream
addled Memories the faces in the water
did not open their mouths but somehow
they spoke to the officer just the same
they spoke of who they were and asked
for help they asked to be seen to be
touched they spoke of the foundation
accusing us of covering up their deaths
and keeping the world from remembering
what happened to them at this point in
the interview the subject became
agitated yelling at Dr Harrison and
refusing to be quiet guards intervened
holding the the subject still as they
fought yelling at Dr Harrison repeating
over and over that they could hear the
body speaking to them every single one
the interview ended when the guards
removed the subject from the room taking
them to the amnestics department to have
all memory of the Bodies In The Water
erase from their mind then they were
forgotten once more I do not recognize
the Bodies In The Water did you repeat
it good we do not recognize the bodies
in the water we can't the motivations of
SCP 2316 if it has any at all are
largely unclear there are those on the
research staff that theorize the hive
mind or Collective consciousness of the
bodies is not malevolent in nature it is
they believe simply trying to make sure
that a tragedy that occurred in that
lake is remembered perhaps many lives
were lost to an anomalous form force in
that Lake and the impact of that massive
tragedy left behind an impression on the
location this impression manifests in
the form of bodies spontaneously
appearing in an impossibly well
preserved condition the Cognito Hazard
of SCP 2316 is not intended to kill
anyone or take them but rather to force
strangers to remember the people who
lost their lives to the lake this sense
of familiarity whether it is false or
not ensures that the dead will not be
forgotten or left alone after all no one
deserves to be left alone though there
have been lives lost to the Cognito
Hazard according to the foundation it is
understandable why the bodies would want
to be recognized to have someone
somewhere know who they were to have
someone remember their names Jeremiah
finan Arthur Scott Denise
Clark where was I oh yes repeat after me
once again I do not recognize the bodies
in the water I do not recognize them I
do
not but that's a lie isn't it I do
recognize them how could I not I know
them they're my friends do you recognize
them look at their faces don't fight the
memories look into their eyes the class
of 1975 they were supposed to graduate
that fall they were just kids group of
innocent kids lost to the dark and deep
what happened to them I can't quite
remember but I know that it mattered
enough for the foundation to keep the
secret and I know that somehow I survive
but I shouldn't have I should be there
with them I should be there there isn't
much time I can hear the guards coming
to retrieve me their footsteps
thundering down the hall I failed the
test and the alarm has gone off they
think I'm lost but I'm not I've never
been less lost in my entire life I've
finally woken up to the truth I remember
I have to go I have to return to the
lake fall of 1975 they went for a swim
my friends they're calling to me I can
hear them so clearly even from so far
away their cries for help ringing in my
ears their voices curling around me
pulling me to the edge of the water the
guards will come for you too they'll
know you've seen this they'll call you
compromis they'll say I succumb to the
effects of the Cognito Hazard they'll
say you did too you'll fail their little
test and they'll say that that makes you
weak and broken but you cannot listen
they're lying it's not a hazard it's a
scream for help they're screaming and
the foundation keeps covering it up they
won't let us find them and they won't
tell us why I have to go back so we can
be together again there are signs posted
all around the lake danger drowning
Hazard those are a trick it's to keep me
out to to keep the truth from me the
barbwire fences around it is it's just
another trick I'll climb over it rung
after rung I don't care if the barbs
tear my clothes or pierce my skin it's
worth it for the truth for the memory
and once I've climbed to the top I'll be
able to see there through the fog I can
see their faces their lips parted in a
constant cry their eyes wide looking for
me my friends my family every face
unlocking a memory long buried I know
them all and I must go further I can't
turn back now I have to wade into the
water let its chills soak into my
clothes down to my bones One Step then
another deeper and deeper the water
lapping at my ankles my knees my thighs
the deeper I go the more sure I will be
that this is where I belong the water
will engulf my chest my neck until my
feet no longer touch the ground I will
be lost in it water flooding into my
mouth pouring into every opening I will
let my body sink down down down to the
bottom where they've been all this time
nestled in the dirt and the dust they've
been so patient but it's finally time
they're ready to be remembered to be
seen to be found they're waiting for me
and they're waiting for you too can you
hear them I'm going now you have to find
me you have to follow me don't let the
guards stop you don't let them wipe it
all away from your mind fight break free
and find the lake hop the fence make
your way into the water you can't leave
me there to fade away floating in the
cold with the rest can you hear us we're
waiting a giant monstrous craike claw
closes around the throat of an
unimaginably huge eel-like Beast the
beast's terrible ring tentacles wrap
around and latch onto the immense
crustation and then the high intensity
beams of gamma radiation start flying
all the while Legions of skinless
Centaur swim in the waters around them
relishing the violence and in the middle
a lone boat The scps mither Man by a
team of mobile task force operatives
that does all it can just to survive
there are those who consider outer space
to be the ultimate achievement in
Exploration the one place that explorers
have yet to chart and understand however
some of the murkiest Mysteries in the
universe are on our own Planet deep down
at the bottom of the ocean 95% of the
deep ocean remains completely unexplored
and the little glimpses we have gotten
paint a picture of something truly alien
giant squids organisms that can breathe
nitrogen luminescent predatory fish and
sharks as old as the Earth itself even
the SCP Foundation is still struggling
to fully grasp the depth of the ocean
and the strange beings that dwell there
one of the most unusual aquatic findings
in the history of the foundation is that
of SCP
3700 SCP 3700 refers to a circular area
in the North Sea with a diameter of 800
km the waters there are abnormally deep
for the region with the seafloor resting
at 5 km beneath the ocean's surface
there are two entities present in the
waters of SCP 3700 designated SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 interactions between these two
entities are responsible for the
anomalous changes to the meteorological
and geological conditions in the area
SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 always interact on the spring and
fall equinoxes of Any Given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year seemingly at random
but what exactly are SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 aside from terrifying creatures of
the deep SCP 37001 is an arthropod
bearing an aesthetic resemblance to the
European Lobster only much much bigger
measuring 6 km in length the creature is
green with a mix of blue yellow pink and
red markings across the top of its exos
that bear the appearance of a woman's
face it has six prehensile limbs four of
which terminate in Claws and eight legs
the entities four eyes are compound and
orange attached to stalks anyone who
gets close enough to observe the
creature's carpes in detail will notice
scars cracks and small holes indicating
years and years of damage SCP 37001 has
several anomalous qualities in addition
to its size in a fight it is able to
strike with its appendages and produce
cavitation bubbles with a force greater
than several tons of Dynamite two of the
entities eyes are capable of blasting
concentrated gamma radiation at a chosen
Target the creature has the ability to
impact the weather around it dispersing
storms that impede its ability to move
with ease and can reach speeds up to 100
km an hour in spite of its immense power
SCP
37001 is not aggressive and tends to
ignore beings in its vicinity other than
SCP
37002 speaking of SCP
37002 it is a 32 km long entity
resembling a pelican eel in all aspects
except for its massive size and the 13
appendages that encircle the middle
section of its body these appendages
which tuck inside its body when not in
use are similar to the T tentacles of an
octopus complete with suckers the
majority of the entity's body consists
of a seny tail terminating in a sharp
point when its mouth is open it is an
estimated 3 km deep its flesh is black
and it has white purple and red
bioluminescent lines in the shape of a
man's face on either side of its torso
SCP 3700 d2's anomalous properties
include the ability to invoke storms
with a severity of category 5 hurricanes
and the ability to produce whirlpools
that draw in any vessel within 150 M so
that it can rip them apart it is also
able to produce high energy sound waves
as well as blue fire which it emits from
its esophagus when the two entities
interact it results in an epic struggle
as each begins attempts to destroy or
subdue the other when one is Victorious
immediate changes to the area follow
when SCP 37 700 D1 winds the storms and
harsh weather in the area will
immediately calm and an era of fertility
and abundance will begin the
reproductive rates of fauna in the ocean
and on the Islands nearby increase
threefold and the crop yield doubles the
ocean itself becomes increasingly active
and the erosion rates of the
archipelago's shores increase fivefold
when SCP 37002 wins however the weather
conditions become dangerous
with raging hurricanes rapidly
fluctuating temperatures and constantly
changing Storm fronts that cause
destruction of buildings and loss of
life naturally this renders any Ocean
Travel in the area extremely difficult
or even impossible aquatic food sources
are driven Away by harsh conditions and
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds water log soil and lack
of sunlight all the while SCP 37002
swims throughout the area praying on
unsuspecting ships and menacing the
coastline until SCP 37001 manifests to
challenge it again SCP 37002 will also
regurgitate instances of SCP
3456 though how or why this is possible
is unknown for those unfamiliar with SCP
3456 they are a group of hairless three
towed horike creatures with thick
translucent skin and human torsos fused
to their backs they are most frequently
seen near sights of War terrorist
attacks and devastating natural
disasters direct observation of one of
these entities will draw their attention
to the Observer who the entity will then
stalk and capture before disappearing
due to their enormous size and ability
to anomalously manifest in their home
Waters SCP 37001 and 2 cannot be
contained at a foundation site instead
their containment is handled by
Foundation Naval task force Delta 7
Northern Storm who Patrol the area in
combination of refurbished battleships
destroyers Cruisers and support craft
additionally measures have been taken to
suppress information about SCP 3700
among the general population details
about the unusual depth of the waters
there have been stricken from public
texts and scientific publication s SCP
37001 has been implanted with donovian
Hollow projectors which disguise it as a
pod of humpback whales if SCP 37001
encounters SCP
37002 Delta 7 May engage protocol winter
Maelstrom this consists of Destroyers
deploying Harpoon based anchors into SCP
3700 d2's head to hold it in one
location next the vessels work together
to Target the entity until SCP 37001 is
able to subdue it if this does not prove
effective and SCP
300-2 cannot be contained then the task
force will Implement protocol tumult at
this point Naval and civilian crafts in
the area must be evacuated trade and
Ferry routes to the archipelagos must be
rerouted for at least 6 months there
will be constant aerial and Naval
engagement with SCP
37002 and constant monitoring for the
reappear of SCP
37001 the behavior of SCP 37001 and SCP
37002 is largely very predictable with
one notable exception on March 20th 2017
a pair of SCP Foundation owned
battleships known as the mither and the
Teran arrived at a point between the
orne Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos
in the North Sea they were accompanied
by the usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 m away from the ship's
anchor points the water began to emit
intense bright rays of light for a
duration of 3 minutes at this point SCP
37001 appeared visible through the
surface of the water Delta 7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the entity
as the ships caught up to the entity it
raised two of its claws into the air
clicking them together in a friendly
greeting the Delta 7 ships followed the
entity along its usual swimming path for
30 minutes and during this time all was
peaceful but this peace did not endure
for long the tide began to change
literally as large black wall clouds
formed overhead the winds picked up and
the waves churned violently in response
as CP 37-1 raised its claws overhead
waving them in a circular motion and
parting the clouds above it and Delta 7
but this effort took a lot out of the
creature and after 30 seconds its
antenna began to droop and it lowered
its CLA PA still the hole in the clouds
remained allowing a spot of sunshine to
break through and beam down on the
foundation vessels 600 M ahead the ocean
waters began to rage and froth spraying
foam and surf into the air SCP 37002
burst from beneath the surface its head
pointed upward it continued to rise
until the tops of its tentacles could be
seen just above the water then stop to
bend its torso and turn its head
horizontally its jaw unhinged exposing
rows upon rows of serrated teeth the
Beast let out a mighty Roar accompanied
by a stream of blue flame at the sight
of its rival SCP 37001 Dove beneath the
surface disappearing from view the scps
mither ordered the rest of the vessels
to engage protocol winter Maelstrom
delta7 scattered out from SCP 3700 d1's
point of submersion and all 13
destroyers fired fired their harpoons at
SCP
37002 embedding themselves in the
entity's head naturally this enraged the
creature and it began to Roar and whale
spinning its lower body vigorously
enough to generate a Whirlpool the
Cruisers opened fire with a combination
of L cannons and conventional Weaponry
in order to distract The Entity as the
Destroyers pulled their Harpoon lines TT
dragging its head in a continuous Circle
while this was taking place the
battleships got into POS position and
prepared to fire on the mither's Mark 3
2 1 fire the first broadside barrage
collided with SCP 3700 D2 and it grunted
in pain thrashing back and forth before
opening its mouth and spewing an
instance of SCP 3456 into the water as
soon as it hit the water the equine
monster began to cut through at a pace
of 50 km an hour making its way toward
the Destroyers particularly the SCP s
skki the skki attempted to retarget its
weapons and prevent the creature from
reaching it but the monster moved too
quickly for the skki to adjust the sky
was lifted out of the water by the
creature as crew members desperately
clung to the railings and their Weaponry
as the crew cowered and tried to fend
off the creature it reached for them
trying to pull them from the ship while
the sky was occupied SCP 3700 D2 was
able to attack again blasting another
ship with a stream of blue fire allow
crack rang out from across the sea as
the skki dropped back into the water the
SCP 3456 instant shrieking in pain SCP
3700 D1 burst through the surface
striking the creature with its Club
likee limbs each blow emitting another
loud crack the third blow tore the
instance in half sending its human torso
kening through the air and pass the scps
mither freed from its attack the CI
moved full steam ahead pulling the
harpoon line Tau again and dragging SCP
37002 out of its path several silky crew
members were thrown overboard during the
struggle and as they struggled to keep
their heads above water SCP 37001
scooped them up placing them onto the
deck of a nearby destroyer and out of
Harm's Way with the crew members rescued
SCP 37001 set its sights on its enemy
swimming towards the edge of the
whirlpool and emitting a luminescent
glow from two of its eyes the Stant
barrage of cannon fire on SCP 37002 was
beginning to take its toll and the
myther ordered the fleet to quote brace
for the killing blow as if responding to
the mither's call SCP 37001 shot several
concentrated blasts of gamma radiation
at its foe leaving large holes in the
creature in their wake SCP 37002
screamed flailing so hard that it
snapped the Harpoon lines and created
waves large enough to push the vessels
backward with its Newfound Freedom SCP
37002 impaled SCP 37001 through the
midsection with its Barbed tip of its
tail lifting it up and out of the water
with the force of the blow SCP 37001
desperately trying to free itself
attacking the tail with its Club likee
limbs but the fight was in vain and
after a moment all movement stopped SCP
37001 was for at least the duration of
this manifestation dead SCP 37002 tossed
the corpse into the water flinging it
past Delta 7 where it crashed into the
water and sank down Into the Depths
below at this point Delta 7 was ordered
to initiate protocol tumult the Delta 7
vessels turned away from SCP
37002 and prepared to evacuate the area
one of the ships the scps strin Beast
slowed behind the rest of the fleet
emitting concerning amounts of smoke
before coming to a stop meanwhile the
enraged and emboldened SCP
37002 expanded the size of its Whirlpool
setting its sights on the retreating
ships and the weakened Stony Beast the
ship tried to flee but the engines were
completely shot and would not respond
the ship was caught in the whirlpool and
pulled against its will toward SCP
3700-3 as the crew looked on in helpless
dread a tentacle Rose from the deep
wrapping around the vessel and dragging
it toward the entity escaping ma
suddenly SCP 37001 exploded from beneath
the surface of the water leaping between
the ship and SCP
37002 cutting the tentacle in half and
freeing the stry beast from its grip SCP
3700 D2 shrieked before closing its jaws
and biting down on SCP
37001 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough damage
to stop SCP 3700 D2 from continuing to
produce its Whirlpool another tentacle
emerged from the water pulling at SCP
3700 d1's legs and ripping them from its
body but SCP 37001 returned the assault
in kind bludgeoning SCP 37002 with its
Club likee limbs from inside of its
mouth all at once SCP 3700 d2's lower
jaw was torn out of place dropping into
the water with SCP 37001 still inside
SCP 37002 thrashed fuly growing steadily
weaker and weaker it released one more
stream of fire before collapsing Delta 7
paused The Retreat watching the scene
for any sign of a winner but after 5
minutes neither entity had moved Delta 7
returned to the side of the battle to
investigate and saw that neither entity
was moving and both appeared to be
deceased shortly after Delta 7 reached
the area both entities disappeared
leaving a single round unidentified off
object that sank below the surface where
SCP
37001 had just been the wall clouds
overhead dispersed leaving standard cumo
nimbus clouds in their place the waters
themselves remained choppy unsure of how
to proceed the scps mither sent a radio
transmission to command uh this is Delta
7 to command we read you Delta 7 command
replied we have a bit of a situation go
ahead Delta 7 SCP
37001 and two are both down command was
silent for 10 seconds utterly baffled by
the information please repeat Delta 7
again the myther said SCP
37001 and two are both down command
ordered the myther to stand by 3 minutes
of radio silence later communication
resumed as they asked are either
entities's effects active ah negative
command is there any trace of either
entity also negative it appears the
anomaly has been NE neutralized Delta 7
is to return to base for debrief
following any recovery efforts with
their next steps clear Delta 7 attached
the stne VES to several tugboats
preparing to pull the vessel to safety
but there was one more surprise waiting
the scps mither began picking up unusual
levels of gamma radiation as well as a
sonar contact at a depth of 3 km they
called command requesting permission to
deploy submersibles for exploration
purposes 1 minute of Silence followed as
the command arrived at a decision
request denied return to base for
debriefing and so Delta 7 began to
evacuate the area once more steaming in
the opposite direction of the battle
over the next 5 minutes CCTV cameras on
the vessels picked up an unusual sight
as the gamma radiation levels continued
to increase the ocean turbulence also
worsened tossing smaller vessels and
nearly causing them to capsize then all
of a sudden the water stilled and four
large yellow orbs appeared below the
surface approximately 300 M from Delta 7
they lingered there for 2 minutes before
Vanishing afterward a new sonar contact
was detected 5 km deep directly beneath
the task force command we've lost the
signal from the previous contact and are
no longer detecting gamma radiation uh
we're detecting new contact 5 km deep
large and metallic after further
deliberation command responded Delta 7
you are authorized to deploy sub ibles
for exploration purposes we advise
should SCP 37002 manifest exploration
teams are to be considered lost and you
are to return to base the consequences
of this incident as well as what else
might be lurking down in the depths
beneath SCP 3700 are still unknown the
year is
1985 16th of February a pair of
researchers aboard a model sm03 deep sea
submersible are descending into the
depth deps of the Atlantic Ocean hours
ago they were somewhere just off the
coast of France surrounded by Blue Sky
the smell of the Sea and the warm
embrace of the Sun but now only cold
Darkness surrounds them the depth of the
ocean so vast and overwhelming even
light could not Escape its grasp the
Twan team are members of MTF gamma 6
also known as the Deep feeders a special
task force that specializes in the
investigation and tracking of deep sea
or Oceanic anomalies their mission to
locate and investigate the wreckage of a
World War II German warship known as the
bismar thought by the general public to
have gone down in the naval battle with
the British in
1941 but the story the public doesn't
know is the real reason the pair of
foundation members were tasked with
locating the ship's wreckage site
unfortunately for these researchers
today would be remembered for something
far worse than they had anticipated ated
radio Transmissions recorded by the
gamma 6 Duo detailed the events that
took place upon finding the bismar
designated as CP
4217 the bismar lay at the bottom of the
ocean partially submerged in the sea
floor but to the astonishment of
researchers it appeared to be perfectly
intact with no signs of damage from its
previous Naval engagements gamma 6
member Charles Miller comments even
after the better part of 5 decades this
ship is still in prec
condition there is no water damage
anywhere that I can see even stranger no
ocean sediment has accumulated on the
whole of the ship whatsoever prompted to
investigate closer agent Victor Miller
begins operation of the crews model rv1
Marine probe an unmanned robotic
exploratory drone that allows the
researchers to explore the interior of
the ship's wreckage what they found
unnerved them or better said what they
didn't find just as the outside of the
vessel appeared free of any corrosion or
wear the interior of the ship was just
as Immaculate the hallways were clean
the walls adorned freshly painted signs
in still legible German even the Nazi
symbols painted onto command centers
still held no sign of disintegration it
was as if the ship had just come off the
assembly line but strangest of all was
the lack of skeletal remains at the time
it was sunk the original crew of the
bismar boasted a minimum of 2,000 and
Men where were the bodies continuing the
mission the researchers piloted their
unmanned drone down the Eerie winding
corridors along several of the inner
corridors of the submerged wreckage of
SCP
4217 the crew find large thick walls of
what appear to be made out of a
rubberlike substance soon they find that
the large vein-like growths extend
throughout the interior of the ship like
tendrils growing in size the closer the
exploratory drone gets to the center of
the vessel all the while a slight hum
sound is picked up by the Craft's sonar
equipment echoing from the center of the
ship a rhythmic pulsing the crew decide
they need to take a sample of the
rubber-like substance back to Foundation
headquarters for testing this would be a
mistake upon cutting into the thick
tentacle likee growths the researchers
noticed something that fills their
stomachs with Dread whatever substance
they had cut into was now bleeding the
team Hears A Distant Rumble growing
steadily louder
suddenly the ship begins to move
shuffling sand and debris strew along
the seafloor clouding the visibility of
the ship terrified the pair hurried to
try and disconnect the cable attaching
the probe to their submersible and
Evacuate the site but it's too late a
booming thud shakes the underwater craft
as a large Shadow covers the glass
window of the submersible alarm systems
go off as cracks start to appear in the
glass surface the pair attempt to Pilot
The Vessel up towards the surface but
they are halted by a strong force
pulling them downward just as the cracks
start to spread across the surface of
the glass A giant shadow looms over the
submersible what is that screams and the
sound of shattering glass can be heard
on the recording as the submersible
implodes from the pressure of the watery
deps since that unfortunate incident
Foundation members have recorded
multiple occurrences of SCP 4217
attacking civilian cargo ships in the
Atlantic particularly off the coast of
the United Kingdom and as far North as
the Greenland sea given its ker
containment classification containment
of SCP 4217 consists of constant
monitoring by Foundation Naval forces
with the cooperation of the British
royal Navy in episodes of aggression or
an agitated or hostile State Naval
forces are instructed to forcibly subdue
SCP 4217 through Naval engagement once
enough damage is sustained SCP 4217
enters a passive State and resub merges
SCP 4217 is divided into two parts SCP
4217 daa is the bismar itself a Nazi era
warship outfitted with an array of eight
main guns 44 secondary armaments and
dozens of units of anti-aircraft
Weaponry SCP 4217 DB refers to the
anomalous seapod organism embedded
inside the hle of the ship SCP 421 17-b
has two large rectangular pupils inside
of octopod eyes that protrude from the
base of the ship as well as 12 100 to
200 M long tendril-like muscular
appendages that extend outward from an
opening in the stern of the vessel SCP
4217 is deemed to be classification risk
class dangerous with reports of it
emitting a mild psionic field within a
20 km radius confusing anything within
range and increasing the likelihood of
Friendly Fire among enemy combatants SC
SCP 4217 A's Hull seems to have the
ability of inorganic regeneration as
damage incurred from enemy vessels seems
to immaculately repair over time
researchers have observed what appears
to be runes or cryptic markings on the
side of SCP 4217 daa's Hall It is
believed these symbols were part of the
original ship's design to bolster the
vessel's defense Integrity though not
immediately visible when the vessel is
taking fire the symbols appear to Glow
in proportion to the amount of damage
being mitigated among its offensive
capabilities apart from the standard
armaments of a World War II era warship
SCP
427a also has specialized Munitions of
an unidentifiable gas compound that is
reported to have mutogenic properties
individuals that have been exposed to
the gas compound undergo rapid
spontaneous metamorphosis at a molecular
level growing an array of evolutionary
attributes which include the
accumulation of reptile-like scales or
Aven feathers in place of skin the
increase or decrease of the number of
Limbs digits or even ocular olfactory or
auditory organs and in one reported case
an event where multiple members of One
crew were fused at a subatomic level
into one functioning organism the more
study into this particular incident is
needed SCP 4217 also has the ability of
subsurface Oceanic mobility and can
submerge itself when not in combat with
enemy vessels underwater propulsion
appears to be Genera ated by the
ejection of water from SCP 4217 DB's
body cavity and reaches a top speed of
approximately 30 knots SCP 4217
undergoes cycles of passive behavior
that is periodically interrupted by
moments of hostility towards civilian
craft particularly resurfacing and going
after transatlantic cargo vessels It is
believed this is analogous to the
history and original Mission of the
bismar operation ryanbang during World
War II the German luwa would was
besieging London in a series of nightly
Air Raids that would be colloquially
known as The Blitz it was the Grand
intention of the third right to cut off
supplies to the British to limit their
resistance to the Nazi war machine
however what pestered the Nazis most and
hindered this effort was the consistent
American Support provided by the US
government in the form of food and
supplies delivered to the British via
Atlantic trade routes by cargo ship the
German bismar and her sister ship the
turits were created for the the very
goal of stopping these transports of
cargo to the United Kingdom as well as
sinking as many Allied vessels as
possible the year is 1937 in a top
secret effort to make preparations for
an approaching War Adolf Hitler turns to
his most trusted expert on the
supernatural Chief SS officer Hinrich
himler among other projects himler
ordered the anner obscura cor a German
organization tasked with the procurement
and investigation of Otherworldly or
otherwise unexplainable phenomenon to
begin the creation of two ships the
bismar and the turits the former named
after the Iron Chancellor ovon bismar
who in 1890 unified the German people
these vessels were to be created using
recently uncovered technological
Oddities the obscura cor had found in
their studies of the occult sources of
information about the exact creation of
SCP 4217 are highly expunged from the
record but bits and pieces did survive
among what little the foundation was
able to collect and in the records of
the USSR after their occupation of
Eastern Germany following the fall of
the Nazi regime during the second world
war the earliest mention of SCP 427's
conception dates back to early 1937 when
a top secret shipment of unknown
materials labeled components of thical
constructs is intercepted by a
foundation agent working under cover in
a German shipment Center outside of
Hamburg the foundation anent Marcus stob
is instructed to maintain surveillance
on the shipment in 1939 upon near
completion of the soon Tobe christened
bismar a second shipment labeled with
the Insignia of the obscura cor is
intercepted by the foundation agent only
this shipment appears unlike any other
reports of the massive shipping
container holding Machinery capable of
Aquatic Life Support indicate organic
living cargo though the foundation agent
was unable to identify the exact nature
of the contents of the shipment straw
reported hearing sounds emanating from
the cargo hold sounds similar to that of
a heartbeat just a year later the bismar
is seen making its first Naval trial run
when it experiences a massive electrical
discharge just offshore shutting the
vessel down momentarily until power was
restored shortly after reports show
luminescent symbols briefly visible on
the hull of the ship theological symbols
for the Layman are symbols that embodied
the study of Miracles because of this it
was apparent to the foundation that some
occult anomaly was responsible for the
strange characteristics of the German
vessel and an order for termination was
reached by the 05 Council the hunt for
SCP
4217 in the Autumn of 1940 under orders
of neutralization of SCP
4217 all active Foundation agents
presiding in Germany were ordered to
converge on the side of the bismar to
stop the completion of the vessel but
when the time came for the operation
every single one of the foundation
agents vanished no records of what
happened were ever found no clothing
notes not even a trace of their EX
resistance was left behind the mission
was deemed a failure and subsequent
attempts to neutralize SCP 4217 became
far more difficult after the bismar
received a full crew of seamen the fully
manned and well equipped SCP 4217 became
a menace to both military and civilian
Craft on the high seas of the Atlantic
at times appearing without warning
seemingly out of thin air SCP 4217
psionic field obscured it from the new
technological advancements in enemy
radar system systems the US government
had in development the ship became a
shadow on the Atlantic a subject of
ghost stories for anyone daring to
assist the British government with the
war effort furthermore SCP 4217 did not
seem to be content with the surrender of
enemy vessels captured enemy ships were
gassed turning the men into manufactured
beasts and then sinking the enemy
vessels to the depths of the ocean even
submarines were no match on one report
describing an attempt to elude The
Vessel by diving below the surface only
to be entangled by enormous squid-like
appendages that dragged the craft back
up to the surface before crushing it in
its grasp fearing the safety of the
public the 05 Council decided they could
not stand by and let more innocent lives
be taken they voted to supersede the
foundation's policy on absolute secrecy
to notify the British government of the
danger SC SCP 4217 posed to Maritime
civilians with cooperation from the
British royal Navy Foundation
Representatives joined the crew crew of
HMS hood and HMS Prince of Wales to
track reports of the bismar being cited
off the coast of Scandinavia in what
history books would come to know as the
Battle of Denmark Straight HMS hood and
HMS Prince of Wales engaged SCP 4217 and
a secondary German warship known as the
prince Yen confused by the ship's
psionic field the British naval ships
experienced trouble identifying the
bismar and engage in Friendly Fire
before being able to regain control of
their armaments concentrating all volley
of fire on SCP
4217 the attack proves futile as after
the Embers and smoke of Munitions fire
wear off the sides of the bismar hull
appear to vibrate with glowing energy
mangled metal begins to straighten back
into perfect frame breaches and armor
begin to heal before the soldiers very
eyes and all that is left as evidence
the ship had ever taken fire is a cloud
of steam emanating from the hull of SCP
4217 the water surrounding the vessel
begin to boil as underwater tentacles
Lurch out and capture the HMS Hood
dragging Her Majesty's ship forward the
men aboard frantically try to regain
control but seconds later are met with
another crisis a salvo of artillery
shells fired from SCP 427's guns hit the
ship severing lines and damaging rail
guns as a mutagenic gas compound starts
to spread among the Royal seamen in mere
minutes the majority of the crew are
engulfed in toxic fumes and experience
vomiting and convulsion
their bodies undergoing rapid
involuntary mutagenesis including the
growth of Limbs the development of fur
feathers and scales in one report it was
said that multiple victims even fused
together to create one single horrifying
entity those exposed to the gashes
compound were designated SCP 421
17-1 the captain of the HMS Hood
barricades himself inside the helm but
the resulting instances of SCP 42171
overpower the ship and neutralize
command in the seconds that follow any
witness of the horror that the men
aboard the HMS Hood experienced is
forever intmed in the watery grave of
the British vessel as the ship is sunk
by a volley of Munitions fire from the
combined might of the German Fleet some
men attempting to jump overboard and
swim to safety are dragged down by their
legs by the mutated instances of SCP
4217 and pulled under lungs filling with
seawater as they scream until their
breath is no more in disbelief the crew
cre of HMS Prince of Wales decides to
retreat in the days that followed at the
bequest of foundation members the
British royal Navy launches a full-scale
Armada to hunt down and neutralize the
bismar though SCP 4217 sustained little
damage in the previous encounter the
ship began leaking a black oil-like
substance thought by SCP researchers to
be an organic waste product of SCP 421
17-b the Allied Naval forces are able to
follow the trail to the coast of France
where under the lead of HMS King George
V British warships surround the German
vessel and opened fire this time they
were ready with approval from the 05
Council Foundation members provide the
British forces with enhanced Munitions
and Armament capable of overwhelming SCP
427's theological defenses on the eve of
battle it appears to the Allied Forces
that the psionic field generated by SCP
4217 is too great as the naval company
find it difficult to land targeted
assaults on the German vessel after
losing several smaller vessels to the
Colossal appendages of SCP
4217 Foundation members on board
authorized the use of a redacted SCP it
is brought in to deactivate SCP 4217
psionic field the tide of The Battle
Turns and after a fierce battle SCP 4217
becomes immobile and unable to return
fire Relentless the British continued
their bombardment until the artillery
Munitions on the ship explode into a
giant Fireball flooding the ship's
compartments with the noxious fumes of
the mutogenic compound its crew members
either jump overboard or are engulfed in
the cloud of gas the British vessels
capture any survivors and watch as SCP
4217 slowly sinks below the waves down
to the depths of the ocean where it
would lay dormant for the next 48 years
SCP
427's 121 surviving crew members were
captured and interrogated most of the
low-ranking German soldiers were police
to British custody 109 of them having
their memory wiped by Foundation staff
12 remaining members of the crew were
sent to site 23 for further detention
and advanced interrogation and 74 of the
instances of SCP 421 17-1 the mutated
subjects were recovered and sent to site
23 for further observation it was
thought that on that day SCP 4217 was
deemed neutralized and no longer a
matter of priority the bismar sunk in to
memory and myth it was only until the
recent Resurgence of SCP 4217 that the
foundation saw the need to collect as
much information on the organism
inhabiting SC SCP 4217 daa as possible
decades old manuscripts and ledgers were
pulled from hundreds of viable sources
from the intelligence then gathered
Foundation members have come to the
hypothesis that the entity powering the
vessel known as the bismar has what is
believed to be extraplanetary origin
World War II era documents uncovered
between Commander Carl reuter of the
German obscura Corp and a doctor Hans
Meyer indicated discovery of an organic
life form of Unknown Origin found in a
crashed aircraft near feldberg Park in
the black forest mountain range in
Germany further correspondence with
obscura cor members Otto Schmidt and
Dietrich clner indicate that researchers
were conducting trials on the creatures
ability to create psionic fields and to
control or confuse enemy subjects within
its range range with a letter from dietr
clner suggesting the creature could be
used as a power source for an
unspecified engine further evidence of
SCP 4217 DB's extraplanetary origin can
be found in a 1993 incident between
Foundation naval ship scps nimed and SCP
4217 this is the only incident on record
where contact was established with the
creature classified as SCP 421
17-b on July 22nd SCP 4217 had
reappeared off the coast of Britain
anticipating hostility scps nemed scps
cesir and scps partholon were instructed
to close in on SCP 427's location with
orders to subdue The Vessel if necessary
however on this occasion SCP 4217 did
not appear to be after any vessel it was
simply drifting along at Sea no
propulsion engines active noticing the
change in SCP 427's Behavior Captain
Kurt Wagner decided to withhold military
engagement and investigate SCP 427's
Behavior sailing within 200 M of the
bismar the scps nemid attempted radio
contact with the German vessel after
repeated attempts at communication the
crew were met with only silence and
static chatter giving up Captain Wagner
puts down the radio receiver when
suddenly the sound of music is heard
playing over the speakers of a ship the
tune is the national anthem of Nazi
Germany the captain hailes The Vessel
again repeating his attempts at
communication do you do you understand
me at first only static can be heard
then came a reply you
ship the ominous voice could be heard
from the speakers the captain hesitated
for a moment members of The Crew looking
at each other with apprehension the
captain replied confirming themselves as
a ship and then ask asking if SCP 4217
knew what it was and where it came from
what followed was the crew of the scps
nemid receiving a video feed from SCP
4217 featuring a high volume of images
in Rapid succession among them were
images of German cities Adolf Hitler's
telecast of the 1936 Olympics an unknown
structure in outer space and an
increasing repetition images of the
planet Jupiter particularly the giant
storm on Jupiter known to the public as
the Great Red Spot or SCP 2399 as
Foundation members know it the
transcript of the radio communication
between Captain Wagner and SCP 2417
stops when the video feed begins to
focus heavily on images of Jupiter SCP
427's responses become more erratic and
agitated as it repeats the words storm
cloud and red the markings on its hole
beginning to light up and the underwater
Shadows of its tentacles beginning to
create create whirlpools of displacement
under the bow of the ship a shrill
shrieking begins to flood out of the
speakers followed by a high piercing
high pitched beeping sound that
overloads the communication equipment
causing Sparks to fly as crew members
cover their ears and hide under control
panels the scps nemit barely escapes as
SCP 4217 becomes hostile using its
massive tendril like appendages to
assail the naval combatants firing its
Armament in all directions after a
fierce battle the foundation Naval
forces were able to neutralize and
subdue SCP
4217 no further attempts at
communication have been recorded to keep
the veil of secrecy Foundation members
constructed a replica ship to be sunk
and intentionally rediscovered by
oceanographer Robert Ballard in
1989 any recent sightings of the Nazi
era bismar are flagged as
misidentification by SCP staff for now
Foundation members continue to monitor
the behavior of SCP 427
and protect the public from its
existence Diego had only just found his
footing when it gave out underneath him
again crashing to the ground he threw
both arms over his head just in time to
protect his skull from the rain of
Boulders that came down past him they
grazed his arms and Jarred painfully
against his muscles but it was better
than having them hit him in the head
without a moment to spare Diego got
straight up to his feet and continued
running back back down the trail he had
been trying to follow the ground shifted
and lurched in all directions under him
threatening to throw off his balance at
any moment having lived in Chile his
whole life he had gotten used to
earthquakes but he had never been in the
center of one like this the problem was
that the trail he had been following to
get up here was disappearing fast as the
dust swirled into the air and boulders
Landing all around him he just had to
keep running in this direction and hope
for the best there weren't any other
options but suddenly he found himself
running uphill stumbling forwards Diego
tried desperately to get his bearings he
had spent the previous 3 hours hiking up
the mountains so how was it that now
that he had turned around and gone back
he was still going uphill it was almost
as if the ground was changing shape
beneath him as he ran dust filled his
lungs as he tried to wipe it away from
his burning eyes yes the ground was
definitely going uphill but it felt
almost as if it was lifting itself up
beneath him as if some tectonic plates
were grinding together creating a new
Mountain beneath his feet Diego lurched
unsteadily and grabbed the nearest rock
to keep his balance feeling the ground
lifting higher and higher beneath him
then all of a sudden the cloud of dust
broke and he was in fresh air Rising
ever higher into the sky the Andy's
mountains stabbed out of the clouds all
around him cutting beautiful shapes
across the Horizon he felt his own
Mountain steadily growing taller than
any of them he dropped down on all
floors and clutched at the ground in
Terror as he tried his best to take in
the shape of what he was now standing
upon how far would you go to prevent a
cosmic level disaster it's one thing to
save your friends and family from an
armed murderer it's another thing to
fight for your country in a world war we
can even just about imagine what it
means to fight for our planet to save
our species from climate change to save
our world from a meteorite but what
would a cosmic disaster look like a
Calamity so Broad in scale that it
surpasses our ability to even perceive
the threat we could Point our most
advanced telescope into deep space and
look straight down the middle of it and
never know it was even there and if that
threat was not simply to the survival of
humanity or planet Earth but to the
survival of existence itself how far
would we go to prevent it what cruel and
inhumane measures would you take to have
such a threat or better yet how many
people would you kill to save the world
this debate is Raging right now as you
sit here and watch this video not among
the foundation but between two scps so
Grand in scale and so advanced in nature
that the foundation has no option but to
sit and listen as the PA debate what to
do with the human race SCP
468-1 was not difficult to discover once
it started moving in fact it was almost
impossible to ignore earthquakes have
been tearing across South America for
centuries destroying homes taking the
lives of innocent people and
fundamentally changing the shape of our
planet itself what most people do not
realize however is that the fault line
running through the Andes mountain range
has actually largely been dormant during
this period the source of the
earthquakes has come from something far
more mysterious our innocent hiker Diego
had been spending the week walking among
the Andes when the earthquake struck you
would be forgiven for assuming as Diego
did that the ground Rising beneath his
feet was a new Mountain forming as the
tectonic plates clashed together but the
Staggering reality of the situation was
that he found himself hiking along the
back of SCP
468-1 as the creature raised its head
into the air Diego saw the head of a
serpent lifting several kilometers away
from him its body stretched and wound
its way through the mountain range
filling the valleys and running beneath
his feet the scale of SCP
468-1 is hard to convey measuring over
500 km in length this serpent is longer
than most US states with a 20 km width
standing on the back of it quite
literally feels like standing on a
mountain range for context The Horizon
at sea level is about 4.8 km away so
multiply that by four and you'll get a
sense of just how wide this thing is
even small movements from this SCP are
enough to trigger continent wide
earthquakes with tremors being felt all
the way around the world upon the
initial discovery of this SCP the
foundation was enabled to determine why
it remains dormant for such long periods
and seems to only awaken sporadically
and for brief periods of time that was
until SCP
45682 was discovered it is little wonder
that the second serpent took so long to
be found its body is comprised almost
entirely of water sand algae and steam
it does not show up on Sonar scans and
is incredibly difficult to detect in the
water even visually its form is Loosely
defined while stormant with broadly
similar measurements to SCP
468-1 this serpent roams the South
Pacific Ocean any Marine creatures that
swim into the scp's body find themselves
undergoing beneficial mutations crabs
grow extra Pinchers Bottom Feeders grow
larger mouths and sharks find themselves
developing heightened senses and even
extra hearts these marine animals seem
to undergo virtually no distress and are
free to exit and re-enter the scp's body
at any point initially SCP 45 568 D2 was
believed to be the peaceful one of the
pair both serpents seem to become active
at the same time while on land SCP
468-1 would wreck havoc with magnitude 7
earthquakes in major metropolitan areas
the sea serpent function was less well
understood employing resonant
frequencies and vibrations this SCP was
able to give its watery body a distinct
form as it rose up from the ocean and
towered above the waves in order to
maintain its shape and control its
movements this SCP employed a huge
amount of energy however the foundation
quickly observed that it was rarely able
to maintain its form for very long as
soon as the sea serpent rose out of the
water its mountainous twin would begin
to move sending Tremors around the world
that disrupted the frequency needed for
SCP
45682 to remain animate exhausted and
unable to maintain its shape the sea
serpent would fall into another period
of dorcy gliding lazily through the
oceans but this dorcy suited the
foundation without the constant seismic
Tremors researchers could work fast two
operating bases were set up to monitor
each SCP two mirrored bases with
mirrored teams in constant communication
with one another as soon as one team
made a discovery it was conveyed to the
others and vice versa one operating base
was set up high in the Andes Mountains
specifically designed to be as
earthquake proof as possible capable of
withstanding earthquakes up to 9.9
magnitude meanwhile in the South Pacific
Ocean an underwater Research Center was
built just above the seabed with regular
vessels drifting out into the unknown to
gather whatever data they could about
the great scps several early findings
stood out firstly SCP
468-1 appeared to have a very different
internal structure from its twin
researchers in this assumed that the
creature would be largely composed of
Earth minerals and rock as its exterior
appearance suggested however scans of
its body indicated the presence of what
can only be assumed to be artificially
created components great gears
resembling Clockwork structures and even
rudimentary circuitry were present
throughout the creature's body the
function or origin of these gears has
yet to be determined especially as there
is no evident way that their movement
corresponds to to the autonomy and
movement of the serpent itself the far
more striking Discovery however came
when the SCP Foundation discovered a way
to communicate with the two beasts ultra
low frequency waves capable of traveling
vast distances even light years were
discovered to be emitted from the two
serpent heads at intermittent periods
the foundation had to develop some of
the largest antenna ever created to pick
up these frequencies and interpret the
data coming through them what they found
were two twins locked in a fierce debate
about the fate of humanity and the
universe itself it was only then that
the motivations of these two serpents
started to make sense in 2010 almost as
soon as the foundation was able to tap
into the frequency they were contacted
directly by a CP
468-1 fion I know that you can hear me I
will not apologize for my actions I know
that I am the reason that millions of
your kind face their demise I know your
pain and I feel it too but I shall never
apologize for it I simply ask you to
listen to myself and to my word cannot
be translated you are curious you can be
patient exercise that and you may one
day understand and listen the foundation
did efforts to contain or destroy the
two serpents were put on the back burner
instead Foundation agents prioritize
spreading disinformation across South
America and Beyond about the source of
these earthquakes the two serpents are
far too large and far too powerful to
overcome or contain instead the
foundation prioritized the use of
amnestic drugs disinformation and the
creation of Fringe conspiracy groups to
discredit any claims of the Serpent's
respective existences meanwhile some of
the most senior leadership figures in
the foundation were and still are locked
in a fierce debate as to what to do with
the twin serpents by listening to the
communication between the two scps the
foundation discovered that SCP
45682 is intent on wiping out the entire
human race the only thing that has
prevented it from being able to do so
thus far has been the existence of the
other serpent every time that SCP
45682 begins to mount an attack on
Humanity
its land bearing twin triggers enormous
earthquakes to disrupt its progress but
why would the sea serpent want to
destroy the human race as Foundation
generals gathered in the deep sea
operations base SCP
45682 came to the observation window to
look them in the eyes as it told them I
am sure you can see it how your world
dies a little bit more every day mostly
by your own hand no you poison the
oceans taint the rivers blacken the
skies you do not need angels of death to
destroy your world but there is
something else I see it in the bottom of
your eyes something
Unforgettable unconceivable ideas
cloaked in Madness and impossible colors
do you think I will let you drag the
rest of the world down with yourself
do you think I will leave this world my
world to Die In Flames it sees your
world and it comes in
fives since this Revelation the
foundation has poured countless hours
and resources into trying to identify a
cosmic threat for well over a decade
many of the smartest scientists the
world has to offer have looked to the
night sky scanning for this impossible
color this shroud of Madness but to no
avail some within the foundation believe
the serpent is lying trying to make up
an excuse to justify its genocide but
information from SCP
468-1 seems to confirm everyone's worst
fears your minds burn bright fasion all
of humanity shines from this rock like a
candle in a dark room it sees you an
idea exists only because something
thought of it have you ever considered
how such terrible Concepts could have
been given form what kind of atrocious
mind could even think about it humans
cannot conceive the colorless green what
if you are playing into this creature's
hands there appears to be an underlying
implication that ideas are the source of
power somehow this colorless green this
unimaginable Cosmic threat seems to be a
monstrous idea in incarnate but whose
idea Humanities there is a deep lore
that the two serpents discuss with one
another one that makes little sense even
to this day to the foundation they talk
of gods and goddesses deities of Flesh
of Steel and gears and of the fives
quite what these creatures are if they
are even creatures at all is a mystery
to the foundation researchers have not
discovered a way of communicating back
with the two serpents directly attempt
to mimic their language or transmit
signals asking questions to them have
largely been ignored instead they
address humanity and the foundation as a
whole seeming to take the view of the
human race as being a collective hive
mind one that they are evidently able to
tap into the pair seem uninterested in
informing us as to exactly what this
threat is or explaining who the gods and
goddesses are perhaps they assume we
know these things already or more likely
they believe that our Consciousness is
not yet capable of perceiving the scale
and depth of the concepts that they are
debating what is clear however is their
shared understanding that if Humanity
were to be eliminated the candle was to
be blown out this Cosmic threat would
pass by the pair have names Tren is the
land serpent while remaining dormant
Munch of the time in an enormous Cave
System beneath the Andes Mountains this
serpent seems Keen to help the
foundation in some way Kai the sea
serpent is intent on sacrificing the
human race for a greater good one far
beyond our understanding speaking to the
foundation in the Andes Mountains
trenten gave a short speech that served
both as encouragement and a terrible
warning of the darkness to come it is
something I like about you fion about
Mankind well it is easy to just take the
simplest path to just give up there will
always be some among you who refuse this
path who do the right thing maybe not
all of you are at this strong but I can
see it in your methods those so-called
containment procedures there will always
be someone who stands up against the
dark even if it takes a thousand million
years to emerge Victorious maybe you can
stop the fief after all ideas can be
killed with better ideas even if it
takes a thousand million years now go
check out SCP 2317 the devour of Worlds
ad door to another world and SCP 001 the
world's gone beautiful